If you want more from the show, join The Rest Is History Club. And with Christmas coming, you can also gift a whole year of access to the history lover in your life. Just head to the rest is history.com and click Gifts. Get no frills delivered. Shop the same in-store prices online and enjoy unlimited delivery with PC Express Pass. Get your first year for 250 a month. Learn more at pceexpress.ca. Flying Emirates business class, enjoying a good night's rest in your lie flat seat.
如果您想了解更多节目内容，请加入“历史即是如此”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）。随着圣诞节临近，您也可以为您生活中的历史爱好者赠送一整年的会员资格。只需前往 therestishistory.com 并点击“礼物”（Gifts）即可。享受便捷的送货服务。在线选购与店内同价的商品，并使用 PC Express Pass 享受无限次配送。首年每月仅需 2.50 美元。详情请访问 pceexpress.ca。乘坐阿联酋航空商务舱，在平躺座椅上享受舒适的睡眠。
You'll see that your vacation isn't really over until your flight is over. Fly Emirates, fly better. This episode is sponsored by Hive. Britain revolutionized the future with the might of industrial power. But now you can transform your own energy future and take control with the power of, of Hive. Hive makes the most of the sun, with solar panels turning sunlight into greener electricity and enabling you to sell excess back to the grid. And Hive's thermostats make it possible for you to heat your home without lifting anything more than a thumb and an impressed brow.
您会发现，直到航班结束，您的假期才算真正结束。搭乘阿联酋航空，体验更佳飞行。本期节目由 Hive 赞助。英国曾以强大的工业力量彻底改变了未来。但现在，您可以利用 Hive 的力量，掌控并改变您自己的能源未来。Hive 充分利用太阳能，通过太阳能电池板将阳光转化为更环保的电力，并让您能将多余的电量卖回电网。Hive 的恒温器让您只需动动手指、挑挑眉毛，就能调节家中温度。
Their heat pumps draw warmth from the air and they keep it exactly where you want it. No smoke, no waste. Hive's EV charger lets your car charge quietly overnight, recharging while you do too. Hive brings it all together, heating, charging and solar, managed from one simple app in a quiet revolution. In the long history of power, Hive helps you finally know yours. Head to hivehome.com to find out more, subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected technology. Paid for a surplus requires SEG tariff. We drove past the Madeleine, down the Schwamsalise, onto the Trocadero, and then to the Eiffel Tower, where Hitler ordered another stop.
他们的热泵从空气中汲取热量，并将其保持在您想要的精确温度。无烟、无浪费。Hive 的电动汽车充电器让您的爱车能在夜间安静充电，在您休息时同步补能。Hive 将供暖、充电和太阳能整合在一起，通过一个简单的应用程序进行管理，带来一场静悄悄的革命。在漫长的能源史上，Hive 助您最终掌握自己的能源。前往 hivehome.com 了解更多信息，具体取决于现场勘测和适用性。Hive 应用程序兼容特定技术。出售多余电量需符合 SEG 关税标准。我们驱车经过玛德莲教堂，沿着香榭丽舍大街，驶向特罗卡德罗，然后到达埃菲尔铁塔，希特勒在那里下令再次停车。
From the Act of Triumph, with its tomb of the unknown soldier, we drove on to the Anvalide, where he stood for a long time at the tomb of Napoleon. Finally, Hitler inspected the Pontillon, whose proportions greatly impressed him. The end of our tour was the romantic, insipid imitation of early medieval domed churches, the church of Sacri-Cure on Montmartre, a surprising choice, even given Hitler's taste. Here he stood for a long time surrounded by several powerful men of his escort squad, while many churchgoers recognized him, but ignored him. After a last look at Paris, we drove swiftly back to the airport.
从凯旋门及其无名烈士墓出发，我们继续驱车前往荣军院，他在拿破仑墓前伫立良久。最后，希特勒视察了万神殿，其建筑比例令他印象深刻。我们行程的终点是那座浪漫而平庸的早期中世纪圆顶教堂仿制品——蒙马特高地的圣心大教堂，即使考虑到希特勒的品味，这也是一个令人惊讶的选择。在这里，他被几名随行护卫队中的强力人物簇拥着站了很久，许多教堂的礼拜者认出了他，却对他视而不见。在最后看了一眼巴黎后，我们迅速驱车返回机场。
By 9 o'clock in the morning, the sightseeing tour was over. It was the dream of my life to be permitted to see Paris. I cannot say how happy I am to have that dream fulfilled. today. For a moment, I've had something like pity for him. Three hours in Paris, the one and only time he was to see it made him happy when he stood at the height of his triumphs. So that was Adolf Hitler's architect and confidant Albert Speer, the man who Hitler was going to commissioned to redesign Berlin as Germania and put Paris in the shade if he won the war. And Speer there is describing one of the most sinister sightseeing tours in history.
到早上 9 点，观光游览结束了。能获准参观巴黎是我一生的梦想。我无法用言语表达梦想成真后的喜悦。今天，我对他产生了一瞬间的怜悯。在巴黎的三小时，他一生中唯一一次见到这座城市，这让他感到幸福，当时他正处于胜利的巅峰。以上就是阿道夫·希特勒的建筑师兼心腹阿尔伯特·斯佩尔的描述，此人本是希特勒计划在赢得战争后，将柏林重新设计为“日耳曼尼亚”并让巴黎黯然失色的建筑师。斯佩尔在这里描述的是历史上最阴险的观光之旅之一。
Dominic, we are in Paris in late June 1940. France has fallen. Speer has joined Hitler for a three-hour tour of the conquered French capital. And I guess it must rank as perhaps the single sweetest moment in Hitler's life, do you think? so up to this point. I mean, this was a man who had fought against the French for four years and his generals had said it couldn't be done, this kind of attack on France, and everything has gone right for him. Yeah, I think there were probably two moments. There's the moment of the Anschluss when he was greeted in Austria, his homeland, as the man who had brought the
多米尼克，我们现在身处 1940 年 6 月下旬的巴黎。法国已经沦陷。斯佩尔陪同希特勒对被征服的法国首都进行了三小时的游览。我想这一定是希特勒一生中最甜蜜的时刻，你觉得呢？到目前为止。我的意思是，这是一个与法国人战斗了四年的男人，他的将军们曾说这不可能做到，这种对法国的攻击，而一切对他来说都进展顺利。是的，我想可能有过两个时刻。一个是德奥合并（Anschluss）时，他在他的祖国奥地利受到欢迎，被视为将德国民族碎片重新整合在一起的人。
sort of the fragments of the German nation together. I guess that was a happy moment for him, and this is another one. And that moment when he says to Speer that the dream of his life, has been fulfilled, you know, Hill is a terrible man, but there is a man under there, right, with ideals and ambitions as ghastly as they may be. And actually, when you think back, we've done the Nazi story in, what, four series, over 18 episodes. We went all the way from the late 19th century through the chaos of the First World War to the rise of the Third Reich. And, you know, we've shown how they've swallowed Austria and Czechoslovakia and Poland and whatnot. and crushed Norway and Denmark.
我想那对他来说是一个幸福的时刻，而这是另一个。当他对斯佩尔说他一生的梦想已经实现时，你知道，希特勒是个可怕的人，但在这之下也是一个人，对吧，有着理想和抱负，尽管它们可能非常可怕。实际上，当你回想起来，我们已经完成了纳粹的故事，在四部系列中，超过 18 集。我们从 19 世纪末一直讲到第一次世界大战的混乱，再到第三帝国的崛起。而且，你知道，我们展示了他们是如何吞并奥地利、捷克斯洛伐克、波兰等等，并粉碎了挪威和丹麦。
And today's episode is about the apotheosis. It's the victory, as you said, that Hitler has been dreaming about since November 1918. It's revenge at last against the French. So let's remind ourselves when we ended last time. In the last episode, we described it on the 10th of May, which is the day Winston Churchill became Prime Minister of Britain. Hitler's troops had launched their invasion in the west of France and the low countries.
而今天的这一集是关于“神化”。正如你所说，这是希特勒自 1918 年 11 月以来一直梦寐以求的胜利。终于对法国人复仇了。那么让我们回顾一下我们上次结束的地方。在上一集中，我们描述了 5 月 10 日，也就是温斯顿·丘吉尔成为英国首相的那一天。希特勒的军队在法国西部和低地国家发动了入侵。
They'd pulled off this extraordinary tactical feat of the sickle cut, where they went through the Ardennes and round and up to the Channel coast and basically trapped the British and French armies against the channel. So that means 400,000 men of the British Expeditionary Force are trapped against the sea in this pocket. And that's pretty much the entirety of the expeditionary force, isn't it, for the British? Yeah, pretty much. And the British, I mean, they've never been a land power.
他们完成了“镰刀收割”这一非凡的战术壮举，穿过阿登森林，绕道并向上直抵海峡海岸，基本上将英法联军困在了海峡边。这意味着英国远征军的 40 万人被困在海峡边的这个口袋里。对于英国人来说，这几乎就是远征军的全部了，不是吗？是的，差不多。而且英国人，我的意思是，他们从来都不是陆地强国。
They don't have loads of other troops to call on if these troops are all captured. They've got Captain Manoring, but that's about it. Exactly. So Hitler is thinking, you know, we pull this off. and it's pretty much game over for the British. That's certainly his mentality. And this scene of them trapped at the channel ports, the panzers advancing and closing in on them,
如果这些部队全部被俘，他们没有大量的其他部队可以调遣。他们有曼沃林上尉，但仅此而已。没错。所以希特勒在想，你知道，我们成功了。这对英国人来说基本上是游戏结束了。这无疑是他的心态。而他们被困在海峡港口的这一幕，装甲部队正在推进并向他们逼近，
this is going to be, you know, it's going to be one of the most terrible moments in French history, the fall of France. And yet, counterintuitively, it ends up becoming one of the most stirring and moving moments in Britain's modern history, the subject of Christopher Nolan's film Dunkirk, which lots of our listeners may have seen.
这将是，你知道，这将是法国历史上最可怕的时刻之一，法国的沦陷。然而，与直觉相反，它最终成为了英国现代史上最激动人心和感人的时刻之一，也就是克里斯托弗·诺兰的电影《敦刻尔克》的主题，我们的许多听众可能都看过。
That bit at the beginning, a sense of impending doom and the Tom is sort of running through the streets and they're picking up these leaflets that say, we surround you, German propaganda leaflets. That's exactly how it was. They were surrounded. Yeah, Kenneth Branagh on a long pier.
开头的那一段，一种迫在眉睫的厄运感，汤米在街上奔跑，他们捡起那些写着“我们包围了你们”的传单，德国的宣传传单。那正是当时的情况。他们被包围了。是的，肯尼斯·布拉纳站在长长的码头上。
Exactly. Looking out to sea, thinking no help will ever come, all of that. So let's pick up the story on the evening of the 23rd of May, two weeks into the German invasion. So that night, the first British troops start being evacuated from Boulogne, which is now under immense relation. relentless German attack.
没错。望着大海，心想不会有任何救援到来，所有这些。那么让我们从 5 月 23 日的傍晚开始讲起，德国入侵两周后。那天晚上，第一批英国军队开始从布洛涅撤离，那里现在正遭受着巨大的、无情的德国攻击。
The Germans have also begun the assault on Calais, and both Boulogne and Calais are doomed. They will fall a couple of days later. I mean, Domit, it's been a pretty grim sequence, hasn't it, for us on the rest of history? Because England lost Calais under Mary in the 16th century about two weeks ago. And now the British troops are being about to lose Calais again.
德国人也开始了对加来的进攻，布洛涅和加来都注定要失败。几天后它们就会沦陷。我的意思是，多米尼克，这对我们“历史即是如此”节目来说是一个相当严峻的序列，不是吗？因为英国在 16 世纪玛丽女王时期失去了加来，大约两周前。而现在英国军队又要再次失去加来了。
I know. Any mention of Calais brings disaster on this show. So there's really only one major channel port left, the port of Dunkirk. And there, almost half a million British French and Belgian troops have taken refuge. Now, a few days earlier, in fact four days earlier, on the other side of the channel, the British had begun making preparations to get them out. And this is the operation that goes down in history as Operation Dynamo.
我知道。在这个节目中提到加来就会带来灾难。所以真的只剩下一个主要的海峡港口了，敦刻尔克港。在那里，近 50 万英法比军队避难。现在，几天前，实际上是四天前，在海峡的另一边，英国人已经开始准备把他们接出来。这就是历史上著名的“发电机行动”（Operation Dynamo）。
So Vice Admiral Bertram Ramsey, who really ought to be a character in PG Woodhouse, he's based in these tunnels underneath Dover Castle. It sounds amazing, actually. His base is there and he has been trying to work out exactly how will we get these troops home. And is this where they come up with the idea of the little ships? The little ships, yeah. They're basically because the big ships can't get in really close. I mean, most people that were rescued were rescued by big ships, spoiler alert.
所以海军中将伯特伦·拉姆齐，他真的应该成为 P.G. 伍德豪斯小说里的角色，他驻扎在多佛城堡下面的这些隧道里。听起来真的很神奇。他的基地就在那里，他一直在努力弄清楚到底该如何把这些部队接回家。这就是他们想出“小船”主意的地方吗？小船，是的。它们基本上是因为大船无法靠得太近。我的意思是，大多数被救的人都是由大船救出的，剧透预警。
But the little ships obviously massive propaganda value. I mean, that's the point of the Christopher Nolan film, isn't it, the little ships? Little pleasure cruisers and fishing ships and things, yeah. Exactly. It's such a moving story if you're British. Now, the stakes could not be higher. That evening, going back to the 23rd of May, Churchill told his staff in London. He said, we cannot leave our army to be slaughtered or to surrender.
但小船显然具有巨大的宣传价值。我的意思是，这就是克里斯托弗·诺兰电影的重点，不是吗，小船？小型游艇和渔船之类的，是的。没错。如果你是英国人，这是一个非常感人的故事。现在，赌注再高不过了。那天晚上，回到 5 月 23 日，丘吉尔在伦敦告诉他的幕僚。他说，我们不能让我们的军队被屠杀或投降。
If we lose the men, then we lose the war. Our men must battle through to Dunkirk. And when they get there, our Navy will get them out. And that night, Churchill goes to see George the 6th, the Buckingham Palace, and he tells him the same thing. We're going to try and get the army back. But, as he knows, Hitler's tanks are now less than 20 miles from Dunk. Kirk and they are closing in all the time. And realistically, it's going to be really difficult
如果我们失去了这些人，我们就输掉了战争。我们的人必须战斗到敦刻尔克。当他们到达那里时，我们的海军会把他们接出来。那天晚上，丘吉尔去白金汉宫见乔治六世，他告诉他同样的事情。我们要尝试把军队接回来。但是，正如他所知，希特勒的坦克现在距离敦刻尔克不到 20 英里，而且它们一直在逼近。现实地说，这将非常困难
to rescue the troops before the Germans get there. But then, then there is a pause, isn't there? And it is one of the key turning points in the history of the Second World War and also one of the most debated. Yes. Because I suppose the question is, why, with victory over Britain seemingly within Hitler's grasp, why does the order go out to the panzers to stop their advance? So let's dig into this, because this, as you absolutely rightly say, this is one of the crucial turning points in the story of the Second World War, you could argue in the story of the Third Reich, the story of Hitler's regime, right? If things go differently here, the whole story might play out differently. So the very next morning, the 24th of May, Hitler flew to Charleville, which is just
在德国人到达之前救出部队。但是，然后，然后出现了一个停顿，不是吗？这是第二次世界大战史上最关键的转折点之一，也是争论最多的转折点之一。是的。因为我想问题是，当对英国的胜利似乎就在希特勒的掌握之中时，为什么会下达命令让装甲部队停止推进？让我们深入探讨一下，因为正如你完全正确地说的那样，这是第二次世界大战故事中的关键转折点之一，你甚至可以说是在第三帝国的故事、希特勒政权的故事中，对吧？如果这里的情况有所不同，整个故事可能会有不同的走向。所以第二天早上，5 月 24 日，希特勒飞往沙勒维尔，那里就在
inside the French border, and that's where General Ron Runstedt, who's commanding the army group has established his headquarters. And Hitler arrives at 1130. And Runstadt says, okay, here's the state of play. My advance guard are now just 15 kilometers from the Allied perimeter and the British are doomed. But Runchtet goes on. He says, the question for us now is how do we finish them off?
法国边境之内，也就是指挥陆军集团的伦德施泰特将军建立总部的地方。希特勒于 11 点 30 分到达。伦德施泰特说，好吧，这就是目前的局势。我的先头部队现在距离盟军防线只有 15 公里，英国人注定要失败。但伦德施泰特继续说。他说，我们现在的问题是如何消灭他们？
Personally, I don't want to risk the tanks. There's a lot of canals in Western Flanders. It's kind of boggy. And that's one of the reasons why Dunkirk has been, you know, provides. to a degree in effective kind of perimeter, doesn't it? Because the canals could stop the Panzer advance in that sense. Yes. And don't forget, the Germans have come an enormously long way very quickly.
就我个人而言，我不想冒险使用坦克。西佛兰德有很多运河。那里有点泥泞。这就是为什么敦刻尔克在某种程度上提供了一个有效的防御圈的原因之一，不是吗？因为运河可以在某种意义上阻止装甲部队的推进。是的。而且别忘了，德国人已经在很短的时间内走了很长一段路。
I mean, anybody who remembers our episodes about the first weeks of the First World War will recall that basically if you have a tremendous advance and a great offensive, the danger is that you're basically just run out of steam because everyone will be just so exhausted. Well, unless you're kind of munching on amphetamins. They'd have gotten through the Ardennes, that they can't do that forever. I suppose. And von Rundstedt says, my men are absolutely exhausted. Ideally, I would like to give them a break, just a little break,
我的意思是，任何记得我们关于第一次世界大战最初几周节目的人都会记得，基本上如果你有巨大的推进和伟大的攻势，危险在于你基本上会耗尽精力，因为每个人都会精疲力竭。好吧，除非你是在吃安非他命。他们穿过了阿登森林，他们不能永远那样做。我想。冯·伦德施泰特说，我的人精疲力竭了。理想情况下，我想给他们一个休息，只是一个小小的休息，
before we turn south towards Paris to finish the job with the French. And Hitler thinks about this, and he says, yeah, I can see that we're, you know, I'd like to take Paris as quickly as possible, just completely knock the French out. So I can see there's some logic in giving your men a little break. But what is more? Herman Goering, the colossal figure of Herman Goering, has assured Hitler that his Luftwaffe, the German Air Force, can easily deal with the British without any need to risk Runstedt's tanks.
在我们转向南方前往巴黎完成对法国人的工作之前。希特勒考虑了这一点，他说，是的，我能看出我们，你知道，我想尽快占领巴黎，彻底击垮法国人。所以我能看出给你的部下一点休息是有逻辑的。但更重要的是什么？赫尔曼·戈林，赫尔曼·戈林这个庞然大物，已经向希特勒保证，他的德国空军（Luftwaffe）可以轻松对付英国人，而无需冒伦德施泰特坦克的风险。
So actually, you know, it's win-win. We can give the panzer commanders arrest, we can give the troops arrest, give Gurings flyers a chance to prove their metal, and we'll wipe the floor with the British at Dunkirk. Well, I mean, I suppose that they're coming off the back of the bombing of Rotterdam with the stucas and everything. And that's been a tremendous success. So maybe they think that they can do the same with the British. Yeah, absolutely.
所以实际上，你知道，这是双赢。我们可以让装甲部队指挥官休息，我们可以让部队休息，给戈林的飞行员一个证明自己实力的机会，我们会在敦刻尔克把英国人打得落花流水。好吧，我的意思是，我想他们是在斯图卡轰炸鹿特丹等行动之后取得的成功。那是一个巨大的成功。所以也许他们认为他们可以对英国人做同样的事情。是的，绝对。
And Gerring is a massive braggart. Gurring will never be honest with you about the limitations of his air force. He makes grand claims, which as we shall see, are not borne out. Hitler then says, okay, fine. And he approves Ranchette's halt order that morning. And the tanks grind to a halt. And it's often said that it is Hitler himself who comes up with the idea, but it clearly isn't, is it? I mean, he's responding in a way that he often doesn't do to suggestions from kind of military heads.
而且戈林是个大吹牛家。戈林永远不会对你诚实地说明他空军的局限性。他提出了宏大的主张，正如我们将要看到的，这些主张并没有实现。希特勒随后说，好吧，没问题。他那天早上批准了伦德施泰特的停止命令。坦克停了下来。人们常说这是希特勒自己的主意，但显然不是，对吧？我的意思是，他以一种他通常不会做的方式回应了来自军事首脑的建议。
The only other thing, though, is you're absolutely right that Hitler is responding to Runstedt's idea, but lots of other commanders think this is a terrible decision. So the lead tank commander, Heinz Gudirian, who is one of the people who come up with a plan in the first place. Yeah, Akhtung Panzer. Akhton Panzer, exactly. he could see Dunkirk very faintly in the distance. I mean, he could absolutely see it. When he gets the order to stop, he is, by his own admission, quote, speechless.
不过，唯一的一点是，你完全正确，希特勒是在回应伦德施泰特的想法，但许多其他指挥官认为这是一个可怕的决定。所以领先的坦克指挥官海因茨·古德里安，他是最初提出这个计划的人之一。是的，“注意坦克”（Achtung Panzer）。“注意坦克”，没错。他可以隐约看到远处的敦刻尔克。我的意思是，他绝对可以看到它。当他接到停止命令时，他承认自己是“目瞪口呆”。
He says, I couldn't believe it. I thought it was the biggest blunder of the war. The commander of the other big German army group in the West, Fedor von Bok, when he was told they've stopped, he said, what? And he immediately complained to headquarters and said, the order must be changed, quote, otherwise the English will transport whatever they want under our very noses from Dunkirk. And that afternoon, the commander-in-chief of the army, Walter von Browkich,
他说，我简直不敢相信。我认为这是战争中最大的失误。西部另一个德国大军团的指挥官费多尔·冯·博克，当被告知他们已经停止时，他说，什么？他立即向总部投诉并说，命令必须改变，引用原话，“否则英国人将在我们眼皮底下从敦刻尔克运走他们想要的任何东西”。那天下午，陆军总司令瓦尔特·冯·布劳希奇，
arrives in Charlville. Now, you'll remember him. He's a man with no spine who's basically massively indebt to Hitler. And even he says, I just can't understand why the tanks aren't advancing on Dunkirk to finish the job. And Hitler and Runcestead say, there is no need. The Luftwaffe are going to finish this off. We'll leave it to Goering and his pilots. And this turns out to be one of the greatest mistakes in military history because Goering has completely misled them. The Luftwaffe are not up to the job. Part of this is because it's very cloudy, but it's also because Gurring consistently underestimates the RAF and he overestimates his own planes and pilots. So in the next 10 days or so, the RAF, the British Air Force, fight manfully
抵达沙勒维尔。现在，你会记得他。他是一个没有脊梁的人，基本上非常依赖希特勒。即使是他也说，我实在不明白为什么坦克不向敦刻尔克推进以完成任务。希特勒和伦德施泰特说，没有必要。德国空军会完成这一切。我们会留给戈林和他的飞行员。这被证明是军事史上最大的错误之一，因为戈林完全误导了他们。德国空军无法胜任这项工作。部分原因是天气多云，但也因为戈林一贯低估了英国皇家空军（RAF），并高估了自己的飞机和飞行员。所以在接下来的 10 天左右，英国皇家空军，英国空军，英勇地战斗
to keep the Luftwaffe at bay. It was often said, and you see this actually, in the Christopher Nolan film. You see this played out at the argument. It is sometimes said, oh, the Air Force didn't help us at Dunkirk. Where were the Air Force? There's a scene in the film when someone shouts, where were the bloody Air Force?
以阻挡德国空军。人们常说，你实际上在克里斯托弗·诺兰的电影中也看到了这一点。你看到这一点在争论中上演。有时人们会说，哦，空军在敦刻尔克没有帮助我们。空军在哪里？电影里有一个场景，有人喊道，该死的空军在哪里？
But actually, Christopher Lennon's film shows. The Air Force were there. They flew 3,000 individual sorties. So they did give the troops air support. The British lost almost 180 planes, but the Germans lost far more planes. They lost 250. And as we will see next time, because German factories are much slower to build planes,
但实际上，克里斯托弗·诺兰的电影展示了。空军在那里。他们进行了 3000 次单独的飞行任务。所以他们确实为部队提供了空中支援。英国损失了近 180 架飞机，但德国损失的飞机要多得多。他们损失了 250 架。正如我们下次将要看到的，因为德国工厂制造飞机的速度要慢得多，
these are losses that they can ill afford. And, Dominic, I mean, actually, there's a pretty continuous process of attrition for the Luftwaffe. So in all that, I mean, they end up losing almost 2,000 aircraft during the Battle of France. And as you say, it wins them France, but it loses them Britain in the long run. Yeah, exactly, exactly. So Hiller doesn't rescind the Holt order. until the evening of the 26th of May. And the next morning, the tanks start moving in,
这些损失是他们无法承受的。而且，多米尼克，我的意思是，实际上，德国空军经历了一个相当持续的消耗过程。所以总而言之，我的意思是，他们在法国战役中最终损失了近 2000 架飞机。正如你所说，这为他们赢得了法国，但从长远来看，这让他们失去了英国。是的，没错，没错。所以希特勒没有撤销停止命令。直到 5 月 26 日傍晚。第二天早上，坦克开始移动，
but those three days have been absolutely crucial, and the damage has been done, because that gives the British a chance to finalise their evacuation plans. So on the evening of the 26th May, the same moment that Hitler is changing his mind, Churchill gives the order, start taking men off the beaches,
但那三天绝对是至关重要的，损害已经造成，因为这给了英国人一个完成撤离计划的机会。所以 5 月 26 日傍晚，就在希特勒改变主意的同一时刻，丘吉尔下达了命令，开始把人从海滩上撤走，
and in the next few days, the ships keep on coming. And to quote General von Bocke again, he's horrified. At Dunkirk, the English are continuing to live, leave. When we finally get there, they will be gone. The supreme leadership's halting of the tank units has proved to be a serious mistake. And he's right. Because they then do not capture Dunkirk for another 10 days. And by then, 900 allied ships, including the famous little ships, the fishing boats, the pleasure cruisers, all of those, the steamboats, all of that, they have rescued
在接下来的几天里，船只不断到来。引用冯·博克将军的话，他感到震惊。在敦刻尔克，英国人继续离开。当我们最终到达那里时，他们已经走了。最高领导层停止坦克部队的行动被证明是一个严重的错误。他是对的。因为他们直到 10 天后才占领敦刻尔克。到那时，900 艘盟军船只，包括著名的小船、渔船、游艇、所有这些、汽船，所有这些，他们已经营救了
338,000 men, far more men than Churchill, or even the most optimistic Allied commander had ever thought possible. So that's out of 400,000? Yeah. The rest are killed or taken prisoner. But even so, I mean, it is not exactly a victory, as Churchill goes on to point out. But it is a Philip, isn't it? Oh, it's massive.
33.8 万人，远比丘吉尔甚至最乐观的盟军指挥官所认为的可能的人数要多。所以那是 40 万人中的一部分？是的。其余的人被杀或被俘。但即便如此，我的意思是，这并不完全是一场胜利，正如丘吉尔后来指出的那样。但这是一个激励，不是吗？哦，太大了。
It's redemption from seeming disaster. Yeah. It's not just the British who get rescued, by the way. It's sometimes thought the British get rescued, and they leave the French behind. not right. Of those men, about 100,000 of them, a French, Belgian, Senegalese, Moroccan and so on. So they're the kind of colonial troops of the Allied forces. So it's not all British troops. But the rearguard, who defended Dunkirk to the end, were French, and there was a lot of bitterness, because they, of course, had been left behind. Now, as you
这是从看似灾难中获得的救赎。是的。顺便说一句，被救的不仅仅是英国人。有时人们认为英国人被救了，他们把法国人留在了后面。这不对。在这些人中，大约有 10 万人是法国人、比利时人、塞内加尔人、摩洛哥人等等。所以他们是盟军的殖民地部队。所以并不全是英国军队。但是保卫敦刻尔克到最后的后卫是法国人，而且有很多怨恨，因为他们当然被留在了后面。现在，正如你
say, the funny thing about it is this is an amazing German victory. The British have been driven off the mainland of Europe, just as Hitler wanted. And Churchill says, in his common speech, which is quoted at the end of the film. Wars are not won by evacuations. Our thankfulness that the escape of our army must not blind us to the fact that what has happened in France and Belgium is a colossal military disaster. And he's right, it is a disaster. But then the point of Dunkirk, the importance of it,
所说，关于这件事有趣的是，这是一场惊人的德国胜利。英国人被赶出了欧洲大陆，正如希特勒所愿。丘吉尔在他的下议院演讲中说，电影结尾引用了这段话。战争不是靠撤离赢得的。我们对军队逃脱的感激之情，不能掩盖法国和比利时发生的事情是一场巨大的军事灾难这一事实。他是对的，这是一场灾难。但敦刻尔克的意义，它的重要性，
is that it allows him to say what he says next, which is, there was a victory inside this deliverance, which should be noted. A miracle of deliverance achieved by valor, by perseverance, by perfect discipline, and so on, blah-di-di-blah. And this is the remarkable thing about it, that Hitler's folly in endorsing the Halt Order and Goering's mad boasting about the Luftwaffe
在于它让他能够说出接下来的话，那就是，这次解救中蕴含着一场胜利，这一点应该被注意到。一种通过英勇、毅力、完美的纪律等实现的解救奇迹，等等，巴拉巴拉。这就是关于它的非凡之处，希特勒在支持停止命令方面的愚蠢，以及戈林关于德国空军的疯狂吹嘘，
have combined to turn a total British disaster into weirdly a kind of psychological and moral victory. And I suppose the role played by the Little Ships, the sense that this is properly a national effort, that everyone is rolling up their sleeves and getting stuck in, this will kind of stiffen the sinews of the mass of British people, that this is a war worth fighting. And that is something that Hitler will never properly get a handle on, is it? He never understands that, I think, because he thinks that the British will come to terms
结合在一起，将一场彻底的英国灾难奇怪地变成了一种心理和道德上的胜利。我想小船所扮演的角色，那种这确实是一项全国性努力的感觉，每个人都在卷起袖子投入其中，这会增强英国人民的意志，这是一场值得打的战争。这是希特勒永远无法真正掌握的东西，不是吗？他从来不明白这一点，我想，因为他认为英国人会在这之后达成协议，但在敦刻尔克之后，很明显他们永远不会。我想这有几个因素。所以其中之一纯粹是实际的。正如伊恩·克肖在希特勒传记中所说，想象一个世界，你知道，那些逃脱的 23 万英国军队没有逃脱而是被俘了。所以 25 万人在战俘营里，那会让丘吉尔在某个时候很难不与希特勒达成协议。你知道，他们不得不组建一支全新的军队，失去了所有的装备。而且他们会在海峡的另一边有所有这些人在纳粹监狱里。还有他们在英国的家人？
after this, but after Dunkirk, it's clear they never will. And I think there's a couple of elements to it. So one of them is purely practical. As Ian Kershaw says in his biography of Hitler, imagine a world in which, you know, the 230,000 British troops who got away had not got away but had been captured. So a quarter of a million men in a prison camp, that would have made it very difficult, you know, maybe for Churchill not to do a deal with Hitler at some point. You know, they've had to raise an entirely new army that have lost all their equipment. And they'd have all these men on the other side of the channel in a Nazi prison. And their families in Britain?
当然。想象一下公众情绪的差异。但我认为你完全正确，小船的神秘感，你知道，人民的战争，人民前来营救他们的军队。你知道，这在克里斯托弗·诺兰电影的结尾得到了象征，当部队到达时，人们为他们鼓掌，给他们茶和三明治之类的东西。你知道，那真的发生了。那绝对发生了。有一个精彩的引语。
Of course. Imagine the difference in the public mood. But I think you are totally right that the mystique of the little show. ships, you know, the people's war, the people coming to the rescue of their troops. You know, that symbolized at the end of the Christopher Leland film, when the troops arrive and there are people clapping them and giving them tea and sandwiches and stuff. You know, that really happened. That absolutely happened. There's a wonderful quote.
我想是在马克斯·黑斯廷斯的书中，来自一位名叫约翰·霍斯福尔的军官。他说，基本上，只有当我们回到家，衣衫褴褛、战败时。人们给我们端上茶，我们才感觉到，我引用，“那种打败了拿破仑并将摧毁希特勒的民族反抗情绪”。你可能会说，好吧，这当然是事后浪漫的、爱国主义的幻想。但我们从当时人们的日记中知道，他们确实有这种感觉。最著名的一位，有一位女性写了历史上最长的日记之一。她叫内拉·拉斯特。她的日记几年前是一个相当大的出版轰动。她来自巴罗。她在日记中写道，就在
I think it's in Max Hastings's book from an officer called John Horsful. And he says, basically, it was only when we got home and we're bedraggled and defeated. And there are people giving us cups of tea that we sensed, and I quote, the national mood of defiance which brought down Napoleon and would destroy Hitler too. And you may say, well, this is, of course, romantic, patriotic fantasy after the fact. But we know from people's diaries at the time that they felt like this. The most famous one, there's a woman who wrote one of the longest diaries in history. She's called Nella Last. Her diaries were quite a big publishing sensation a few years ago. She's from Barrow. And she wrote in her diary just the day after
行动结束后的第二天。她说，我读了这个故事，我忘记了我是一个中年家庭主妇，有时起床很累，背痛。这个故事让我觉得自己是不朽的、永不衰老的一部分。不知何故，我觉得一切都是值得的，我很高兴我和营救者以及被营救者属于同一个种族，意思是国籍。这就是，你知道，那种非常感人的、根深蒂固的东西，很容易被嘲笑，但在 1940 年夏天的那些周里，在心理上显然非常重要。而希特勒不会，我的意思是，他不欣赏它。
the operation ended. She said, I read the story and I forgot I was a middle-aged house. wife, who sometimes got up tired and had backache. The story made me feel part of something that was undying and never old. Somehow, I felt everything to be worthwhile, and I felt glad I was of the same race, meaning nationality, as the rescuers and the rescued. And that's, you know, that sort of very moving, routing stuff, which is easy to sneer at, was obviously psychologically so important in those weeks in the summer of 1940. And which Hitler will not, I mean, he doesn't appreciate it.
他不欣赏它对英国士气的影响。所以他会觉得英国人决定继续战斗令人费解。是的，无法理解。但这可能是关键的解释。但当然，与法国形成了巨大的对比，因为英国和法国在 30 年代都是非常分裂的国家。但在英国，敦刻尔克的奇迹和小船等等有助于巩固民族决心，而在法国，失败使社会更加分裂。
He doesn't appreciate the effect it's had on British morale. So he will find it puzzling that the British decide to fight on. Yeah, can't get his head around it. But this is kind of probably the key explanation. But also, of course, there is a massive contrast with France because Britain and France were both very divided countries in the 30s. But in Britain, the miracle of Dunkirk and the little ships and everything helps to solidify national resolve, whereas in France defeat fractures society there even wider.
我想你是对的。我想如果我不指出英国比 1930 年代的法国更具共识性，那我就失职了，这不仅要归功于斯坦利·鲍德温明智而勇敢的领导。斯坦利·鲍德温，是的。斯坦利·鲍德温，他主持的国家比 1930 年代的法国总理所主持的国家要稳定和团结得多。但你是对的。明显的对比是法国。
I think you're dead right. I think someone would be remiss of me, not to point out that Britain was much more consensual than 1930s France, thanks not least to the wise and gallant leadership of Stanley Baldwin. Stanley Baldwin, yeah. Stanley Baldwin, who presides over a much more settled in a united country than French prime ministers do in the 1930s. But you're right. The obvious contrast is with France.
现在，有趣的是，在英国，大多数关于此的描述，在流行想象中，它们从敦刻尔克直接跳到了不列颠战役。事实上，中间什么都没有。但那是不对的。德国人现在正向南前往巴黎。在接下来的几周里，法国人打得相当顽强。所以德国人在敦刻尔克之后每天损失的人数实际上比之前更多，因为法国人正在拼命战斗以保卫他们的首都。
Now, interestingly, in Britain, most accounts of this, kind of in the popular imagination, they skip from Dunkirk straight to the Battle of Britain. In fact, there's nothing in between. But that's not right. The Germans are now heading south towards Paris. And in the next couple of weeks, the French fight quite hard. So the Germans actually lose more men per day after Dunkirk than they did beforehand because the French are fighting desperately to defend their capital.
我能引用一位领导反击的法国上校吗？这是一位名叫夏尔·戴高乐的上校。他负责法国第 4 装甲师。他在海峡海岸的阿布维尔发动了反击，战斗中，他没能赶走德国人，但确实成功地至少阻止了德国人的推进一两天。这实际上对敦刻尔克非常重要，因为它分散了德国军队的注意力
Can I just cite one French colonel who leads a counterattack? And this is a colonel called Chal de Gaulle. He's in charge of the French 4th Armoured Division. and he launches a counter-attack at Abbeville on the Channel Coast, and the battle, he fails to dislodge the Germans, but it does succeed in halting the German advance at least for a day or two. And this is actually very important for Dunkirk because it serves to distract German forces
否则可能会增加敦刻尔克前线的压力。所以让我们不要忘记戴高乐。好吧，事情是这样的，如果你是戴高乐，对吧，或者如果你是看着这个故事的法国爱国者，你会说，这些英国播客讲述故事的方式很好，这是人们在英国总是讲述的方式。从法国的角度来看，这是一个英国人逃跑的故事，正如他们在 1914 年情况变糟时威胁要做的那样。而且正如他们在整个战争期间一直在做的那样，对吧？我的意思是，这发生在挪威。
that otherwise might have added to the pressure on the front line at Dunkirk. So let's not forget DeGol. Well, here's the thing, if you're DeGol, right, or if you're somebody at French Patriots looking at this story, You say, it's very nice the way these British podcasters tell the story, which is the way that people always tell us in Britain. From a French perspective, this is a story of the British running away, as they had threatened to do in 1914 when things went badly. And as they had been doing throughout the war, right? I mean, it happened in Norway.
没错。英国人逃跑了，保住了他们的军队，他们逃跑了，而我们正在拼命战斗以保卫我们的首都。基本上，每个人都嘲笑我们，说，你知道，法国的奖杯柜是空的。但事实是我们以压倒性的劣势打得很好，所有这些，因为实际上他们确实处于压倒性的劣势。德国人现在有更多的师，因为法国军队正在瓦解。德国人更擅长使用坦克。德国人有更多的空中力量，当然德国人有纪律和士气
Right. The British have run away, saved their army, they've run away, and we are fighting desperately to defend our capital. And basically, everyone laughs at us and says, you know, the French trophy cabinet is bare. but the truth is we fought very well against overwhelming odds and all the rest of it because actually they are against overwhelming odds. The Germans have more divisions now because the French army is disintegrating. The Germans have better at using their tanks. The Germans have far more air power and of course the Germans have the discipline and morale
这来自于作为一支推进中的军队。所以到 6 月 6 日，德国人已经突破了法国防线并越过了索姆河。到 9 日，他们在鲁昂。到 10 日，他们越过了埃纳河。所以所有这些在 1940 年会有如此共鸣的地方，因为这些都是第一次世界大战的地名，而德国人只是像压路机一样碾过它们。是的，我记得当我去了伊普尔，我祖父被毒气毒死的地方，他们有成排成排的坟墓，我想是加拿大人，它们布满了弹孔，你知道，那是 1940 年发射的。哇。是的。我只是想，哦，天哪，你知道，我的意思是，想象一下所有这些，你知道，我们又来了。我认为这在英语世界可能被低估了，对于比利时和法国的平民来说，这是在一代人中第二次发生。想象一下那种压倒性的痛苦，你知道，当你意识到它正在以比以往任何时候都更大的规模再次发生时。这就是为什么，正如我们上次所说，人们记得 1914 年。他们读过关于波兰的故事。他们读过像格尔尼卡和 1930 年代末日本人洗劫中国城市这样的事情。他们害怕当德国人进入他们的城市时会发生什么。
that comes with being an advancing army. So by the 6th of June, the Germans have broken the French line and crossed the river Somme. By the 9th, they're in Rouen. By the 10th, they've crossed the river Ayn. So all these places that would have had such. resonance in 1940 because these are all the place names from the First World War and the Germans are just steamrollering past them. Yeah, I remember when I went to Eap, where my grandfather was gassed and they had rows and rows of graves, I think of Canadians, and they were peppered
这就是为什么像里尔这样的地方有这些非凡的故事，里尔，十分之九的人口去了乡村，逃离了城市。沙特尔，有它著名的，你知道，建筑之类的。2.3 万人住在沙特尔。当德国人到达那里时，只剩下 800 人了。其他人都走了。这是西欧历史上最大的难民危机。我不知道一些听众是否读过伊莱娜·内米洛夫斯基的《法兰西组曲》。这些书捕捉到了
with bullet holes, you know, that had been fired in 1940. Wow. Yeah. I just thought, oh my God, you know, I mean, just imagine all that, you know, and here we go again. This is, I think what's underappreciated possibly in the English-speaking world, that for the civilians in Belgium and France, this is happening for the second time in a generation. Imagine the sense of crushing misery, you know, as you realize it's happening all over again on a greater scale than ever before. And that is why, you know, as we said last time, people remember 1914. They've read the stories about Poland. They've read about things like Gernica and the sack of Chinese cities by the Japanese in the late 1930s. They're terrified of what will happen to them when the Germans get into their cities.
这种完全混乱和恐怖的场景。街上的马车，家庭匆忙寻找避难所，并被德国空军从空中轰炸。你知道，到处都是尸体。是的，斯图卡那种纳兹古尔式的俯冲
And that is why these extraordinary stories of places like Leal, Leal, nine-tenths of the population took to the countryside, fled the city. Chartre, with its famous, you know, architecture and stuff. 23,000 people lived in Chart. By the time the Germans get there, there are only 800 left. Everybody else has gone. And this is the biggest refuge. crisis in Western European history. I don't know if some listeners have read the Sweet Francaise books by Irene Nemirovsky. These books capture
伴随着它们可怕的尖叫声。是的，简直太可怕了。所以想象一下成为高层的人。所以提醒人们，总理，他才上任几个月，保罗·雷诺，非常聪明的人，但非常，我正要说，但非常矮，我应该说非常聪明和非常矮。是的，我很高兴你纠正了自己。现在，自 5 月 19 日以来，他们有了一位新的军事首脑，就是马克西姆·魏刚，我们上次描述过他。他 70 多岁了。他被从退休中召回。
this scene of total chaos and terror. Carts and the streets, families rushing to find sanctuary and being pounded from the air by the Luftwaffe. You know, bodies everywhere. Yeah, the kind of Nazgol-esque descent of the Stoekers
而雷诺在法国危难时刻召回的另一个人是第一次世界大战的伟大英雄。这就是在 1916 年凡尔登防御战中集结法国军队的人。他现在 84 岁了，锐利的蓝眼睛，像通条一样笔直。而且仍然留着非常典型的第一次世界大战胡子，不是吗？一个合适的，是的，1910 年代的胡子。他是“老元帅”，菲利普·贝当，他们召回他是因为他们认为他将成为法国反抗人民的象征。贝当一直担任驻西班牙弗朗哥将军政权的大使。
with their terrifying wine. Yeah, just horrific. So imagine being the people at the top. So to remind people, the Prime Minister, who's only been there for a matter of months, Paul Reynel, very clever guy, but very, I'm about to say, but very short, very clever and very short, I should say. Yeah, I'm glad you corrected yourself. Now, since the 19th of May, they've had a new military chief who is Maxine Vagant, who we described last time. He's in his early 70s. He's been recalled from retirement.
雷诺说，我希望你回到法国，在我们危难时刻做我的副手。贝当去见弗朗哥说，我要去法国了。弗朗哥说，别费心了。你输了，没必要去。而贝当也许相当不祥地，一些听众可能会想，对他说，我的国家已经被打败了。他们召回我是为了讲和并签署停战协定。这是 30 年马克思主义工作的结果。他们召回我是为了接管国家。
And another man who Reno has recalled in France's hour of need is the great hero of the First World War. And this is the man who had rallied the troops, French troops at the defence of Verdun in 1916. He is now 84 years old, piercing blue eyes, ramrod straight. And with very much a First World War moustache still, hasn't he? A proper, yeah, in 1910's moustache. He is Le Vieux-Marchelle, the old marshal, Philippe Petin, and they've recalled him because they think he will be a symbol to the people of French defiance. Petin had been serving as ambassador to General Franco's regime in Spain.
现在，对于那些希望贝当能挺起脊梁对抗法西斯主义的人来说，这听起来可能有点不祥。所以早在 6 月 8 日，他们就讨论了向德国人寻求条款。雷诺反对。他说，我们同意伦敦，我们永远不会寻求停战，你知道，独立的停战。我们承诺不会签署单独的和平。魏刚将军说，什么？英国人，我的意思是，英国人完全让我们失望了。他们把我们的后卫留在了后面。魏刚和贝当都同意，一切都完了。法国输了。我们输掉了战争。
And Reno says, I want you to come back to France and be my deputy in our hour of need. Petin went to see Franco and said, I'm off to France. Franco said, don't bother. You've lost no point in going. And Peyton perhaps rather ominously, some listeners may think, said to him, My country has been beaten. They're calling me back to make peace and to sign an armistice. This is the work of 30 years of Marxism. They're calling me back to take charge of the nation.
魏刚说，听着，你还记得我们之前在 1870 年、71 年输给德国人时发生了什么吗？巴黎被革命性的左翼公社接管了。然后基本上发生了一场小规模的内战。成千上万的人死了。当军队转向公社时，街道上血流成河。动物园里的所有动物都被吃掉了。哇。没人想要那样。难道没人关心动物园里的动物吗？
Now, that might sound a bit ominous to people who are hoping that Peiang is going to stiffen the sinews to stand up to fascism. So as early as the 8th of June, they discuss asking the Germans for terms. Rayneau is against it. He says, we agree with London that we would never seek an armistice, you know, an independent armistice. We promised we wouldn't sign a separate piece. General Vagin says, what? The British, I mean, the British have totally let us down. They've left our rear guard behind. Both Vagont and Peta agree, it's all up. Francis is lost. We've lost the war.
没错。还有动物园里的动物。魏刚说，听着，那应该是我们的首要任务。确保这种情况不再发生。我们不能有无政府状态。我们必须保持秩序。基本上，我们需要与德国人打交道，否则一切都会在混乱中崩溃。贝当说，我同意魏刚的意见。
And Vagin says, listen, do you remember what happened when we lost to the Germans before in 1870, 71? Paris was taken over by the revolutionary left-wing commune. There was then, basically, a little civil war. Thousands of people died. as the army turned on the commune and the streets ran with blood. And all the animals in the zoo got eaten. Wow. No one wants that. Will no one think of the animals in the zoo?
瓦甘说，听着，你还记得我们上次在1870到1871年输给德国人时发生了什么吗？巴黎被革命性的左翼公社接管了。当时基本上发生了一场小规模内战。成千上万的人死去了，军队镇压了公社，街道上血流成河。动物园里的所有动物都被吃掉了。哇。没人想要那种结果。难道就没人关心动物园里的动物吗？
Exactly. And the animals in the zoo. And Vagant says, listen, that should be our priority. It's making sure that doesn't happen again. We can't have anarchy. We must keep order. And basically, we need to deal with the Germans, otherwise everything will collapse in chaos. And Paitan says, I agree with Vagin.
没错。还有动物园里的动物。瓦甘说，听着，那应该是我们的首要任务。我们要确保那种事不会再次发生。我们不能陷入无政府状态。我们必须维持秩序。基本上，我们需要对付德国人，否则一切都会在混乱中崩溃。派坦说，我同意瓦甘的看法。
I don't think we should ask London. I think basically the British dragged us into this war. And we spent too much time kowtowing to the British. And basically, France should come before anything else. And I would have thought also a consideration is the future of Paris, right? Because bombs have already been dropped on the air ministry and the citron works. Not the citron works. On the citron works. But suppose the fate that was inflicted on Rotterdam is inflicted on the city of light. Yeah. So the French government decide to declare Paris in open city, don't they? And on the 10th of June, the government flees Paris.
我认为我们不应该去问伦敦。我认为基本上是英国人把我们拖进了这场战争。我们花在对英国人卑躬屈膝上的时间太多了。基本上，法国应该高于一切。我想还有一个需要考虑的问题是巴黎的未来，对吧？因为炸弹已经投在了航空部和雪铁龙工厂。不是雪铁龙工厂。是在雪铁龙工厂。但假设鹿特丹遭受的命运降临到这座光之城身上。是的。所以法国政府决定宣布巴黎为不设防城市，不是吗？6月10日，政府逃离了巴黎。
And there's this famous description by an American broadcaster, Edward Severade. And he wrote, Paris lay inert, her breathing scarcely audible, her limbs relaxed. And the blood flowed remorselessly from her manifold veins. Paris was dying like a beautiful woman in a coma. Yeah. Now, I'll tell you who's left Paris. Two million people, including the government. so they have fled Paris on the 10th of June.
美国广播员爱德华·默罗有一段著名的描述。他写道：巴黎躺在那里，毫无生气，呼吸几乎听不见，四肢松弛。鲜血从她众多的血管中无情地流出。巴黎像一个昏迷的美丽女人一样正在死去。是的。现在，我来告诉你谁离开了巴黎。两百万人，包括政府。所以他们在6月10日逃离了巴黎。
Reynot and Coe, they head towards the Loire. And Reino establishes himself in the Chateau de Chisay, which is just outside the very beautiful city of Tor. And he's brought not his wife, from whom he is estranged, but in very Gallic style, he's brought his mistress. So actually quite Nelsonian style. I guess so. This is Countess Elene de Porte.
雷诺和他的同僚们向卢瓦尔河方向撤退。雷诺在谢尔河畔的城堡里安顿下来，那里就在非常美丽的图尔市郊外。他带来的不是他分居的妻子，而是以非常高卢人的风格，带来了他的情妇。所以实际上是非常纳尔逊式的风格。我想是这样。这就是埃莱娜·德·波特伯爵夫人。
And Elene de Porte has quite a bit of, baleful influence on what happens next. Now, I hate to be seen to be mean about a woman on the show, Tom, as you know. Yet another mistress, the object of Sandbrookie and I. She has had the most terrible press. I think of almost any woman we've ever done on the show. Scholdegor used to call her the turkey. Churchill called her the parrot.
埃莱娜·德·波特对接下来发生的事情有着相当大的、有害的影响。汤姆，你知道，我讨厌在节目中显得对一个女人刻薄。又是一个情妇，我和桑德布鲁克的目标。她所受到的媒体评价之差，我想几乎超过了我们节目中提到过的任何女性。戴高乐过去常叫她“火鸡”。丘吉尔叫她“鹦鹉”。
And Churchill's chief diplomatic advisor, Sir Robert Van Sittart, called her, and I quote, a poisonous and promiscuous troll. That's a phrase to remember. Even the American correspondent Vincent Sheehan wrote afterwards, she was not chic, she was not charming, and she was not intelligent, but she behaved as if she had some vested right, whether constitutional or divine, in the government of the French Republic. Now, why does all this matter?
丘吉尔的首席外交顾问罗伯特·范西塔特爵士称她为——我引用一下——“一个有毒且滥交的巨魔”。那真是一个值得记住的短语。甚至美国记者文森特·希恩后来也写道，她既不时髦，也不迷人，更不聪明，但她的行为举止仿佛她对法兰西共和国的政府拥有某种既得权利，无论是宪法赋予的还是神授的。那么，这一切为什么重要呢？
It matters because she's a massive anti-Semite, she's also massively pro-fascist, and she is constantly, you know, by night, she's constantly urging Rayno, sack all your generals, and do a deal with the Germans as quickly as possible. Well, the Germans aren't that bad. So that's a bit of a problem, I think. So what does he see in her? God knows.
这很重要，因为她是一个极端的反犹主义者，也是一个极端的亲法西斯主义者，而且她不断地——你知道，在夜里——不断地敦促雷诺，撤掉你所有的将军，尽快与德国人达成协议。好吧，德国人没那么坏。所以我认为这有点问题。那么他到底看中了她什么？天知道。
I mean, who can say? Remember Napoleon with Josephine, there was something called the zigzags, wasn't there? Yeah, the zigzags. And nobody knows what that was, but it was great fun and involved them going to bed together. Maybe the zigzags have made their reappearance. I don't know. Anyway, so this is a slightly awkward environment. And the next day, the 11th of June, Winston Churchill joins the Merry Party.
我是说，谁说得准呢？记得拿破仑和约瑟芬吗，有一种叫“之字形”的东西，不是吗？是的，“之字形”。没人知道那是什么，但那很有趣，而且涉及他们一起上床。也许“之字形”又重现了。我不知道。总之，这是一个有点尴尬的环境。第二天，6月11日，温斯顿·丘吉尔加入了这个快乐的聚会。
Well, it's never a party unless Churchill, sir. Exactly. Loads of champagne and dundee cake. So he flies to a chateau near Orleans, where the French leadership are waiting to meet him. And for the next day and a bit, they try to hammer out a strategy. And Churchill says, I have an excellent idea. Why don't you go to Brittany? Hold out in Brittany, you know, make it a redoubt.
嗯，没有丘吉尔先生，这就不叫聚会了。没错。大量的香槟和邓迪蛋糕。所以他飞往奥尔良附近的一座城堡，法国领导层正在那里等着见他。在接下来的一天多时间里，他们试图敲定一项战略。丘吉尔说，我有一个绝妙的主意。你们为什么不去布列塔尼呢？在布列塔尼坚持住，你知道，把它建成一个堡垒。
Like asterix. And Vagant says, you're amazing. Mad. That's an insane idea. That will never work. And Churchill says, a campaign of guerrilla resistance. And Petin says, that would destroy France. That can't work either. And Vagin says to Churchill, now is the decisive moment in the war. The British ought not to keep a single fighter in England. They should all be sent to France. And Churchill then says to him, no, this is not the decisive moment. the decisive moment will come when Hitler hurls his Luftwaffe against Britain. If we can keep the command of the air over our island,
就像阿斯泰利克斯一样。魏刚说，你疯了。疯狂。那是个疯狂的主意。那根本行不通。丘吉尔说，一场游击抵抗运动。贝当说，那会摧毁法国。那也行不通。魏刚对丘吉尔说，现在是战争的决定性时刻。英国人不应该在英国保留哪怕一架战斗机。它们都应该被派往法国。丘吉尔随后对他说，不，这不是决定性时刻。决定性时刻将出现在希特勒将他的空军投向英国之时。如果我们能保持我们岛屿上空的制空权，
then we will win it all back for you. Whatever happens here, we are resolved to fight on forever and ever and ever. And actually Churchill is right. That's actually how Britain wins the war. Like he's not wrong. The trouble is that's really not what a Frenchman wants to hear. Basically, you know, you have to fight on to the end. You'll lose, but eventually we'll win it all back for you, so don't worry.
那么我们就会为你们赢回一切。无论这里发生什么，我们都决心战斗到底，永远，永远，永远。事实上丘吉尔是对的。这实际上就是英国赢得战争的方式。他并没有错。问题是，这真的不是法国人想听到的。基本上，你知道，你必须战斗到底。你会输，但最终我们会为你们赢回一切，所以别担心。
I don't think any patriotic Frenchman wants to hear that. Does this conversation determine Rayno's decision that, yeah, it's over, do you think? No, because even at this stage, Rayno has not quite given up. Because after he's gone, Churchill goes, and some of them clearly are very pleased to see the back of him. And then Rayneau and co sit around. And Rayno says, you know, clearly we are going to lose, but we could go into exile and continue the fight from London, very much like the Norwegians have done, let's say, or the Dutch. And Vagant says, that's pointless.
我想没有哪个爱国的法国人想听到这些。你认为这次谈话决定了雷诺“一切都结束了”的决定吗？不，因为即使在这个阶段，雷诺也没有完全放弃。因为在他走后，丘吉尔离开了，他们中的一些人显然很高兴看到他离开。然后雷诺和同僚们坐在一起。雷诺说，你知道，显然我们要输了，但我们可以流亡并从伦敦继续战斗，就像挪威人或荷兰人所做的那样。魏刚说，那毫无意义。
That old fool Churchill is talking rubbish. Because once Hitler is finished with us, then he will take Britain. He'll be in London before you know it. There's no point in us hiding in London. The British are doomed. He famously says, doesn't he, that Britain will have her neck rung like a chicken. Yes. To which Churchill later responds, some chicken, some neck.
那个老傻瓜丘吉尔在胡说八道。因为一旦希特勒解决了我们，他就会占领英国。你还没反应过来他就会到伦敦了。我们躲在伦敦毫无意义。英国人完了。他有名言，不是吗，说英国会被像鸡一样扭断脖子。是的。丘吉尔后来回应道：好一只鸡，好一个脖子。
Exactly, exactly. And Vagon keeps going on. We have to stay here in France and stop the anarchy and revolution. And actually, Vakor is telling Rano things that are not true. So Vagor is telling him at this point, revolution has already broken out in Paris. The specter of a left-wing commune has, you know, re-as awoken from the grave. And that's actually not right. That hasn't happened.
没错，没错。魏刚继续说。我们必须留在这里，在法国，阻止无政府状态和革命。事实上，魏刚在告诉雷诺一些不真实的事情。所以魏刚此时告诉他，巴黎已经爆发了革命。左翼公社的幽灵已经，你知道，从坟墓中苏醒了。而那实际上是不对的。那并没有发生。
Anyway, the next day, Churchill comes back. They can't get rid of him. He flies back to France. This time he goes to tour. There's been some amusing airfield action in earlier episodes. So I'm glad to have some more. He arrives at the airfield, there's nobody to meet him. They've all gone to lunch, splendidly.
总之，第二天，丘吉尔又来了。他们无法摆脱他。他飞回了法国。这次他去了图尔。在之前的剧集中有一些有趣的机场行动。所以我很高兴能再多一些。他到达机场，没有人来接他。他们都去吃午饭了，真是太棒了。
So eventually Churchill and his entourage find two French Air Force officers who agreed to give them a lift. And of course, Churchill being Churchill, they go straight to the Hotel Grande Britannes to have lunch themselves. There are refugees outside staring through the windows and kind of rattling the doors. And Churchill is completely unperturbed by this. And he says, you know, let them stare. It's very good for them to see the Prime Minister of Great Britain having his lunch.
所以最终丘吉尔和他的随从找到了两名同意载他们一程的法国空军军官。当然，丘吉尔就是丘吉尔，他们直接去了大不列颠酒店自己吃午饭。外面有难民盯着窗户看，还敲打着门。丘吉尔对此完全无动于衷。他说，你知道，让他们盯着看吧。让他们看到大不列颠的首相在吃午饭对他们很有好处。
She'll inspire them and all this kind of thing. Whether it does, I'm not sure. Anyway, he goes to the town hall to see Reno. By this point, Vagant and Pater are no longer come into these meetings, which tells its own story, because they basically think it's pointless. And Churchill is very emotional. He says to Reno, we ask you to fight on as long as possible, if not in Paris, at least behind Paris, in the provinces down to the sea. Then if need be in North Africa, the alternative is the destruction of France. And that, of course, is the rhetoric that Churchill is coming out with later about Britain, right?
这会激励他们之类的。我不知道这是否有用。总之，他去市政厅见雷诺。到这个时候，魏刚和贝当已经不再参加这些会议了，这本身就说明了问题，因为他们基本上认为这毫无意义。丘吉尔非常激动。他对雷诺说，我们请求你们尽可能长时间地战斗，如果不在巴黎，至少在巴黎背后，在各省，一直到海边。如果需要，就在北非。另一种选择是法国的毁灭。当然，这就是丘吉尔后来关于英国所说的言论，对吧？
You know, we're fighting on the landing grounds, all of that. But Peyta has already said that actually that strategy would be the destruction of France because it would see, you know, her cities and her monuments destroyed. Churchill would, of course, said, I'm sure, I know what Churchill would have said to that. He would say nothing will ensure the destruction of France more than the collapse of her spirit and her morale. You can rebuild cathedrals, but the stain of defeat can not. never be wiped away. But he can say that because he has a strip of water between him and the Germans, I guess. But there's another man who agrees with him, who is French, who is there.
你知道，我们在登陆场战斗，诸如此类。但贝当已经说过，实际上那种战略将是法国的毁灭，因为它会看到她的城市和古迹被摧毁。丘吉尔当然会说，我相信，我知道丘吉尔会对此说什么。他会说，没有什么比精神和士气的崩溃更能确保法国的毁灭了。你可以重建大教堂，但失败的污点却永远无法抹去。但他能这么说是因为他与德国人之间隔着一条海峡，我想。但还有另一个人同意他的观点，他是法国人，也在那里。
And that is then you mentioned him earlier. He's just been appointed the Under Secretary of State for War. And he is an officer called Charles de Gaulle. De Gaulle is the only person who seems to agree with Churchill at these meetings. And Churchill kind of responds to him, doesn't he? and says l'om du destin, the man of destiny. Yeah, he whispers it, the man of destiny to de Gaulle on the way out, and de Gaulle says nothing, he's just impassive, as he always is. I mean, that would make a great film, actually. People have done loads of Churchill films,
那就是你之前提到的那个人。他刚刚被任命为战争部副部长。他是一位名叫夏尔·戴高乐的军官。戴高乐似乎是这些会议中唯一同意丘吉尔观点的人。丘吉尔对他做出了回应，不是吗？说“命运之人”。是的，他在离开时对戴高乐耳语了“命运之人”，而戴高乐什么也没说，他只是面无表情，一如既往。我是说，那会是一部很棒的电影。人们拍过很多丘吉尔的电影，
but they've never done Churchill and the French as a film. So there's one other amazing bit of high drama at this meeting. I mentioned Countess de Port, the promiscuous troll or whatever said he was described as being. The fascist troll, the worst kind of troll. She bursts into this meeting and she shrieks at the top of voice, Mr Churchill, my country is bleeding to death. And then she launches herself at him and tries to scratch his face. And a French officer shouts, get that woman out of here for the dignity of France.
但他们从未把丘吉尔和法国人拍成电影。所以这次会议还有另一个令人惊叹的高潮。我提到了德·波特伯爵夫人，那个滥交的巨魔或者无论她被描述为什么。那个法西斯巨魔，最糟糕的那种巨魔。她冲进会议室，尖叫着说，丘吉尔先生，我的国家正在流血致死。然后她扑向他，试图抓他的脸。一名法国军官大喊，为了法国的尊严，把那个女人带出去。
And basically Churchill's bodyguard, who's called Walter Tommy Thompson, he sort of has to wrestle this woman away from Churchill and drags her out of the room. And then when he searches her, he finds that she has a knife on her person, which is a very low moment, I think, in the history of the Entente Cordial between our two great nations. And Dominic, meanwhile, on the very same day, so the same afternoon, at 3 o'clock, the Germans have reached the River Marne, and people who listened to our series on the First World War will remember that that was the key turning point in the early
基本上丘吉尔的保镖，名叫沃尔特·汤米·汤普森，他不得不把这个女人从丘吉尔身边拉开，把她拖出房间。当他搜查她时，发现她身上带着一把刀，我认为这是我们两个伟大国家之间“英法协约”历史上非常低落的时刻。与此同时，多米尼克，就在同一天，也就是同一个下午3点，德国人已经到达了马恩河，听过我们第一次世界大战系列节目的听众会记得，那是第一次世界大战早期战役的关键转折点，
campaigns in the First World War, but not on this occasion. And from the River Marne, the Germans can see the Eiffel tower in the distance and Paris has already been declared an open city and at dawn the next day, Friday the 14th of June, 1940, the first German units start entering the center of the French capital. And the fall of Paris is the most emblematic symbol around the world of the catastrophe that has befallen the Allies, right? it is indeed so by the evening the germans have hoisted a swastika over the arc de triumph and they have climbed the french cut the lift cables to try to stop the Germans getting to the top of
但这次不是。从马恩河，德国人可以看到远处的埃菲尔铁塔，巴黎已经被宣布为不设防城市。第二天黎明，1940年6月14日星期五，第一批德国部队开始进入法国首都中心。巴黎的陷落是全世界范围内盟军所遭受灾难的最具象征意义的标志，对吧？确实如此，到傍晚时分，德国人在凯旋门上悬挂了纳粹旗，他们还切断了电梯缆线，试图阻止德国人到达埃菲尔铁塔顶部。
the Eiffel tower so do you know what the Germans did they climbed 1,665 steps of the tower to raise the swastika flag over the Eiffel tower very soon that tower would be decorated with a vast banner, the words of which read, Deutschland Siegd out Alan Fronten. Germany is winning on every fronton. So one month and four days after the first German droops crossed the frontier into France, Paris has fallen, and we will find out what happens next after the break. At Capital One, we're more than just a credit card company.
所以你知道德国人做了什么吗？他们爬了1665级台阶，在埃菲尔铁塔上升起了纳粹旗。很快，那座塔将被一面巨大的横幅装饰，上面写着：Deutschland siegt auf allen Fronten。德国在各条战线上都在获胜。所以，在第一批德国军队越过边境进入法国一个月零四天后，巴黎陷落了，休息过后我们将了解接下来发生了什么。在第一资本，我们不仅仅是一家信用卡公司。
We're people just like you who believe in the power of yes. Yes to new opportunities. Yes to second chances. Yes to a fresh start. That's why we've helped over 4 million Canadians get access to a credit card. Because at Capital One, we say yes, so you don't have to hear another no. What will you do with your yes? Get the yes you've been waiting for at Capital One.ca.C.A. slash yes.
我们和你们一样，相信“是”的力量。对新机遇说是。对第二次机会说是。对重新开始说是。这就是为什么我们已经帮助超过400万加拿大人获得了信用卡。因为在第一资本，我们说“是”，这样你就不用再听到“不”了。你会用你的“是”做什么？在CapitalOne.ca/yes获得你一直在等待的“是”。
Terms and conditions apply. This episode is brought to you by Aura Frames. History is full of gifts, but the best are those that last. Because photographs have become our modern heirlooms. They're like fragments of the present already turning into history. Orra Frames let you relive these memories every day or give them to someone you love. That is our beloved producer Theo pointing at a kebab in Sarajevo. Preload the photos before it leaves the box, add a message, and you can keep updating it from anywhere. Unlimited storage, no subscription, just memories. For a limited time, visitoraframes.co.com.uk and get £45 off Aura's best-selling Carver matte frame, named the top frame by the independent, and use the promo code history at the checkout.
条款和条件适用。本集由Aura Frames赞助。历史充满了礼物，但最好的礼物是那些持久的。因为照片已经成为我们现代的传家宝。它们就像已经变成历史的现在的碎片。Aura Frames让你每天都能重温这些记忆，或者把它们送给你爱的人。那是我们敬爱的制片人西奥在萨拉热窝指着一个烤肉串。在它离开盒子之前预装照片，添加一条信息，你可以在任何地方不断更新它。无限存储，无需订阅，只有回忆。在有限的时间内，访问auraframes.co.uk，购买Aura最畅销的Carver哑光相框，可享受45英镑的优惠，该相框被《独立报》评为顶级相框，并在结账时使用促销代码history。
That's A-U-R-A-U-R-A-C-C-C-O-D-U-K promo code history. This exclusive Black Friday, Cyber Monday deal is their best of the year. So order now before it ends. Support the show by mentioning us at checkout. Terms and conditions apply. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. Paris has fallen to the Nazis and Dominic now for the leadership of France, the democratic leadership. The end is just days away, isn't it? Yes. So Paul Reno and his ministers have now
那是A-U-R-A-C-O-D-E-U-K，促销代码history。这个独家的黑色星期五、网络星期一优惠是他们一年中最好的。所以现在就订购，以免优惠结束。在结账时提到我们以支持本节目。条款和条件适用。你好，欢迎回到《其余皆历史》。巴黎已经落入纳粹手中，多米尼克，现在对于法国的领导层，民主领导层来说，终点只有几天之遥了，不是吗？是的。所以保罗·雷诺和他的部长们现在已经
arrived in Bordeaux. They're going further and further south. Bordeaux is a city in total, an utter panic crowded with hundreds of thousands of refugees. Bercreino and his mistress, the Countess de Porte, check-in to the Hotel Splendid. That's a great name for Hote. Yeah. So they're normally in France, so they're not, there's the Splendid, the Bristol and the Grande Britannes. Those are the kind of traditional names for French hotels, aren't they? So on, I don't know why Bristol.
到达了波尔多。他们正向更南边撤退。波尔多是一座陷入彻底恐慌的城市，挤满了成千上万的难民。雷诺和他的情妇德·波特伯爵夫人入住了斯普兰迪德酒店。那是个很棒的酒店名字。是的。所以他们在法国通常是这样，不是吗，有斯普兰迪德、布里斯托尔和大不列颠。这些是法国酒店的传统名称，不是吗？所以，我不知道为什么叫布里斯托尔。
What is it with Bristol? I think that's one of the most famous hotels in Paris. I mean, mad. There's no Hotel Norwich. Bristol's a fine city, though. Yeah, it is. Okay, so on Saturday the 15th of June, the French cabinet again discussed whether to surrender. and Reyno really does want to fight on from abroad.
布里斯托尔是怎么回事？我想那是巴黎最著名的酒店之一。我是说，疯了。没有诺里奇酒店。不过布里斯托尔是个好城市。是的，确实。好的，所以在6月15日星期六，法国政府再次讨论是否投降。雷诺确实想从国外继续战斗。
He does not want to give up, but he is outvoted by his cabinet. Most ministers agree with Vagant and Peta that they should ask Hitler for terms. Rayno at this point wants to quit at once, but he's persuaded out of it. And that night at dinner, he has the most blazing row with Elend de Port. He has found in her bed, she's been hiding secret telegrams from London. She's clearly been reading them. Oh, I see. So it's not secret telegrams.
他不想放弃，但他被内阁投票否决了。大多数部长同意魏刚和贝当的观点，即他们应该向希特勒寻求条件。雷诺此时想立即辞职，但他被劝阻了。那天晚上吃晚饭时，他和埃莱娜·德·波特发生了最激烈的争吵。他在她的床上发现了她一直藏着的来自伦敦的秘密电报。她显然一直在读它们。哦，我明白了。所以这不是秘密电报。
that have been sent to her from spies in London. No, no. She's going to the stenographer's office and basically grabbing telegrams. Knicking crucial communications. Exactly. They have a massive row and he throws water over her at dinner in front of everybody to sort of punish her. So it's an awkward situation. You know, no one knows where to look.
那是从伦敦的间谍发给她的。不，不。她去速记员办公室，基本上是在抢电报。偷窃关键通讯。没错。他们大吵了一架，他在晚餐时当着所有人的面把水泼在她身上，算是惩罚她。所以这是一个尴尬的情况。你知道，没人知道该往哪看。
I suppose it's keeping people's minds off the fall of Paris. It is, I suppose, yeah. So the next day is Sunday, 16th of June, an incredibly dramatic day. 7.30 that morning, Churchill is at checkers in the English countryside, and he is woken by his aide. Churchill hates being woken up early because of his ludicrous hours. And he's told Rayneaux is about to quit as French Prime Minister, and he's going to be replaced by his deputy, Marshal Pater. Churchill eats his breakfast very quickly. I mean, he still has his breakfast, fair play to him. And then he rushes to London. And there, an amazing thing,
我想这让人们不去想巴黎的陷落。我想是这样，是的。所以第二天是6月16日星期日，极其戏剧性的一天。那天早上7点30分，丘吉尔在英国乡村的契克斯，被他的助手叫醒。丘吉尔讨厌被早早叫醒，因为他那荒谬的作息时间。他被告知雷诺即将辞去法国总理职务，并将由他的副手贝当元帅接替。丘吉尔吃早餐吃得很快。我是说，他还是吃了早餐，对他来说很公平。然后他赶往伦敦。在那里，一件令人惊奇的事情，
actually, which is actually weirdly little known, I think, among the British public, that the British cabinet approve a plan to merge Britain and France into a single country, a Franco-British Union, which would have a common citizenship, common defence, and common foreign and economic policies. And the point of doing this is not because they want to rebuild the empire of, you know, Henry II or something. It's because they think this will give them the legal powers to take the whole French army to Britain and to take control of the French Mediterranean fleet. And they sort of think that it might maybe stiffen some people in France's nerve, you know, that the British are really so committed, they're going to merge
实际上，我认为在英国公众中鲜为人知，英国政府批准了一项将英国和法国合并为一个国家的计划，即“英法联盟”，它将拥有共同的公民身份、共同的防御以及共同的外交和经济政策。这样做并不是因为他们想重建亨利二世之类的帝国。而是因为他们认为这将赋予他们法律权力，将整个法国军队带到英国，并控制法国的地中海舰队。他们认为这可能会加强法国一些人的神经，你知道，英国人是如此坚定，他们甚至要将自己的国家与法国合并。
their country with France. Anyway, they put this to de Gaulle, who has flown to London as Rayno's representative. And amazingly, de Gaulle agrees. So you would think that the girl of all people, the man who vetoed Britain's attempt to join the Common Market, would be against this, but he says, fine, you know, an extremist, let's do it. And he rang Rayno that day and dictated it over the phone. And Rayno said, fine. So that evening, Crano puts this plan to his cabinet. It's meant to be a surprise, but actually, Countess Deport has been up to her old tricks. Oh, goodness. She has seen the stenographer's copy of the telegram and she's, and of the sort of document, and she's leaked it to all Reino's ministers. Look at this. This is terrible. Do you know, we've had loads of mystery.
总之，他们把这个提议给了戴高乐，他作为雷诺的代表飞往了伦敦。令人惊讶的是，戴高乐同意了。所以你会认为戴高乐这样的人，那个否决了英国加入共同市场尝试的人，会反对这一点，但他却说，好吧，你知道，极端分子，让我们做吧。他那天给雷诺打了电话，并在电话里口述了它。雷诺说，好吧。所以那天晚上，雷诺把这个计划提交给了他的内阁。这本应是一个惊喜，但实际上，德·波特伯爵夫人一直在耍她那套老把戏。哦，天哪。她看到了速记员的电报副本，并将其泄露给了雷诺所有的部长。看看这个。这太可怕了。你知道，我们在《其余皆历史》中讲过很多神秘事件。
on the rest of history. But I think she's the worst. She's bad, isn't she? She's not great. Rayno's ministers hate this idea. They say, come on. This just makes us an appendage of Britain, will be a British dominion.
但我认为她是其中最糟糕的。她很坏，不是吗？她不太好。雷诺的部长们讨厌这个主意。他们说，得了吧。这只会让我们成为英国的附庸，我们将成为英国的领地。
And Peyton says, you are asking us to agree fusion with a corpse. You know, they've got it very clear in their heads that Britain is dying. Payton is clearly a bad man, Tom. And it's very clear, I think, that a lot of them, deep down, would rather have an armistice with the Germans.
贝当说，你是在要求我们同意与一具尸体融合。你知道，他们脑子里很清楚，英国正在死去。贝当显然是个坏人，汤姆。而且我认为很清楚，他们中的许多人内心深处宁愿与德国人达成停战协议。
They would... be a British dominion or anything of that ilk. Yes, because an armistice with the Germans will enable those on the right to come down hard on their compatriots who are on the left. So they're still to a degree thinking in terms of party politics rather than of national survival. And also, of course, they think the Germans are going to win the war at this point. None of them think that Britain can win the war. They just assume the Germans are going to win.
他们宁愿……成为英国的领地或任何类似的东西。是的，因为与德国人的停战将使右翼人士能够严厉打击他们左翼的同胞。所以他们在某种程度上仍然在从党派政治的角度思考，而不是从国家生存的角度。当然，他们也认为德国人此时会赢得战争。他们中没有人认为英国能赢得战争。他们只是假设德国人会赢。
So the next day, the 17th of June, two more very dramatic developments. So overnight, Rayno quits, as had been advertised, and Peyton becomes Prime Minister. And at 11.30 that morning, Peyton broadcasts to the French people, and he says, I'm going to ask Hitler for terms. He says, I've sent a message to the enemy commander to ask him if he would meet with me as one soldier to another after the fight, and honorably seek a way to put an end to hostilities. But you know, what's not honorable is that he basically tells things. the French army to put down their weapons, even before the armistice has been agreed. Yeah. And as soon as people hear that broadcast, they stop fighting, a lot of them.
所以第二天，6月17日，又发生了两件非常戏剧性的事情。所以一夜之间，雷诺辞职了，正如预告的那样，贝当成为了总理。那天上午11点30分，贝当向法国人民广播，他说，我将向希特勒寻求条件。他说，我已经向敌军指挥官发了信息，询问他是否愿意在战斗结束后像士兵对士兵那样与我见面，并体面地寻求结束敌对状态的方法。但你知道，不体面的是，他基本上告诉法国军队放下武器，甚至在停战协议达成之前。是的。一旦人们听到那个广播，他们就停止了战斗，他们中的许多人。
They're like, well, what's the point? Why carry on if we're going to lose anyway? Now, meanwhile, de Gaulle, who had once been Peyton's protégé, I mean, this is the thing. He had looked up to Peyton as a mentor. He's come back from London. And when he comes back and he hears, we're asking for peace, de Gaulle is totally devastated. You know, he'd wanted to fight on. and de Gaulle knows that basically
他们想，好吧，有什么意义呢？如果我们反正都要输，为什么要继续？现在，与此同时，曾经是贝当门生的戴高乐——我是说，这就是重点。他一直把贝当视为导师。他从伦敦回来了。当他回来听到“我们正在寻求和平”时，戴高乐彻底崩溃了。你知道，他一直想继续战斗。戴高乐知道，基本上
Peyton is taking power and that he, de Gaulle, as a hawk, will probably be arrested because that's what happens to Peyton's other critics and opponents within the regime. He goes to see Reynneau, presumably the Hotel Esplandide, and Rayno has not yet handed over
贝当正在掌权，而他，戴高乐，作为一个强硬派，可能会被逮捕，因为这就是贝当政权内其他批评者和反对者的下场。他去见雷诺，大概是在斯普兰迪德酒店，而雷诺还没有交出
this sort of, I don't know whether there's a briefcase or something, that has the Prime Minister's secret funds in it. And Reino gives de Gaul a hundred thousand francs and says take the money go to london you know do what you can and that's what de goul does even as peyta is speaking to the french people de goul is in a plane going back to london and when he gets to london there he makes the very famous radio appeal to the french people that all french school children are now very familiar with he basically says to them we appear to have lost but it's not final
那个，我不知道是不是公文包之类的东西，里面有总理的秘密资金。雷诺给了戴高乐十万法郎，说拿着钱去伦敦，你知道，尽你所能。这就是戴高乐所做的。就在贝当向法国人民讲话时，戴高乐正在飞往伦敦的飞机上。当他到达伦敦时，他在那里向法国人民发出了非常著名的广播呼吁，所有法国学童现在都非常熟悉。他基本上对他们说，我们看起来好像输了，但这不是最终结果。
France is not lost. I, General de Gaulle, appeal to the French people to join me. The flame of French resistance must not be extinguished and will not be extinguished. It's one of the most stirring and defining moments in modern French history and now a huge part of French identity. But almost nobody hears it, right? Yeah, let's reign on that French parade. Nobody's listening is they're all listening to Marshall Payton. I don't think it's raining on their parade because I think it's, you know, it's an acorn from which a mighty oak grows, and it actually makes the story of the free French all the more dramatic than nobody hears it. But it is a single candle that is blowing in an almighty tempest. Yes, I think that's a nice way of putting it.
法国没有输。我，戴高乐将军，呼吁法国人民加入我。法国抵抗运动的火焰绝不能熄灭，也不会熄灭。这是现代法国历史上最激动人心和最具决定性的时刻之一，现在也是法国身份认同的巨大组成部分。但几乎没有人听到它，对吧？是的，让我们给那场法国游行泼点冷水。没人听，因为他们都在听贝当元帅。我不认为这是在泼冷水，因为我认为，你知道，这是一颗橡子，从中长出了一棵参天大树，而且它实际上让自由法国的故事变得更加戏剧性，因为没人听到它。但它确实是狂风中摇曳的一支蜡烛。是的，我认为这是一个很好的说法。
Because, I mean, an almighty tempest, my God, this is the most traumatic moment in French history, without a doubt. And how it happened has been argued about ever since the French collapse in the face of, you know, the German invasion. And Petin and his allies right from the moment he takes office say, we lost because we were sick, because there was a sickness in French society. And some historians have said that since, you know, that France was fatally divided and demoralized even before the war began. There are others. So there's a great historian Jackson who's written a brilliant book on The Fall of France. And Julian Jackson says, you know, everything that you say of France, you know, you could say it of other countries, too.
因为，我是说，一场狂风，天哪，这无疑是法国历史上最痛苦的时刻。它是如何发生的，自法国在德国入侵面前崩溃以来，人们一直在争论。贝当和他的盟友从他上任的那一刻起就说，我们输了是因为我们病了，因为法国社会有一种疾病。一些历史学家此后也这样说，你知道，法国在战争开始前就已经致命地分裂和士气低落了。还有其他人。所以有一位伟大的历史学家杰克逊写了一本关于《法国的陷落》的精彩著作。朱利安·杰克逊说，你知道，你对法国所说的一切，你也可以对其他国家说。
The truth is they lose on the battlefield because of bad intelligence and bad tactics. Yeah, I think that's clearly the case, because had they bombed, for instance, the tanks as they were going through the Ardennes, then Germany would have lost, and we'd probably be having these discussions about the sickness in German society. Well, I mean, we do have discussions about the sickness in German society, but you know what I mean? I do know what you mean, exactly. I think it's true that the British and French generally are too cautious and they're too
事实是，他们因为糟糕的情报和糟糕的战术而在战场上失败了。是的，我认为显然是这样，因为如果他们轰炸了，例如，坦克穿过阿登森林时，那么德国就会输，我们可能就会讨论德国社会的疾病了。好吧，我是说，我们确实讨论过德国社会的疾病，但你知道我的意思。我确实知道你的意思，没错。我认为英国人和法国人通常太谨慎了，而且他们太
hesitant throughout the whole war. I mean, that's what a lot of military historians say, that basically the value of human life matters a lot to a British or a French general. You know, they're very conscious of the lessons of the First World War. They don't want to be the butchers who send men, you know, advancing towards, you know, machine guns. The Germans are gamblers, and that comes from the top. And the French and the British are very reluctant to take decisions in 1940.
犹豫不决，贯穿整个战争。我是说，这就是许多军事历史学家所说的，基本上人类生命的价值对英国或法国将军来说很重要。你知道，他们非常清楚第一次世界大战的教训。他们不想成为把士兵送去冲向机枪的屠夫。德国人是赌徒，这来自高层。而法国人和英国人在1940年非常不愿做出决定。
And I think there's also a sense, though, that the French lack a bit of solidarity when things are going badly. You know, this is a massive question, so any short take on it will be a bit simplistic. But even in the early days of the campaign, General Gamelin, who was Vagorn's predecessor, said, it's clear that some of our soldiers don't really believe in the war. They're not massively fired up. They don't really believe in their leaders. Julian Jackson in his book on the Fall of France quotes, a young sergeant who had been, perhaps tellingly, on the far right in the 1930s,
而且我认为还有一种感觉，法国人在情况变糟时缺乏一点团结。你知道，这是一个巨大的问题，所以任何简短的回答都会有点简单化。但即使在战役初期，魏刚的前任甘末林将军也说，很明显，我们的一些士兵并不真正相信这场战争。他们没有被大规模地激发起来。他们并不真正相信他们的领导人。朱利安·杰克逊在他的《法国的陷落》一书中引用了一位年轻中士的话，他可能很有说明意义地在20世纪30年代属于极右翼，
who said, what will really annoy me in this. this war is if I end up dying for values in which I do not believe. And Dominant, what is the name of that, a young officer? That young officer's name was Francois Mitterrand. So the future socialist president of France. But there are other examples. I mean, Jackson also quotes a philosophical George Friedman who was serving as a lieutenant. And Friedman said, you know, when I look at the people around me, I don't detect a huge
他说，在这场战争中真正让我恼火的是，如果我最终为我不相信的价值观而死。多米尼克，那个年轻军官的名字是什么？那个年轻军官的名字叫弗朗索瓦·密特朗。也就是未来的法国社会主义总统。但还有其他例子。我是说，杰克逊还引用了一位担任中尉的哲学家乔治·弗里德曼的话。弗里德曼说，你知道，当我看着周围的人时，我没有察觉到
amount of pain at the misfortunes of our country, more a kind of relief that it's all over. Thank God that that's done. I mean, maybe you could say there would have been people in Britain who would have acted similarly had they been defeated. Thank God, that's over. I mean, I'm sure there would have been actually a few. But I think France is much more divided than Britain in the mid-1930s. And that lack of ideological cohesion, I think, does actually play a part, especially when things go badly. You know, they find it harder to fall back on a sort of patriotic solidarity, I would say. Richard Evans, in his books on the Third Reich, points out that there are French
对我们国家的不幸有巨大的痛苦，更多的是一种一切都结束了的解脱感。感谢上帝，这一切都结束了。我是说，也许你可以说，如果英国人被击败，也会有类似行为的人。感谢上帝，那结束了。我是说，我肯定实际上会有一些。但我认为法国在20世纪30年代中期比英国分裂得多。而且我认为这种缺乏意识形态凝聚力的情况确实起到了一定作用，尤其是在情况变糟时。你知道，他们发现更难回归到一种爱国团结，我会这么说。理查德·埃文斯在他的《第三帝国》系列丛书中指出，有一些法国
conservatives who had always despised French democracy, much as German conservatives had despised the Weimar Republic. You know, French conservatives had often admired Hitler and Mussolini and spoken of their, you know, the lessons that could be drawn from fascism. And so when they are beaten, they say, well, you know what, actually, this might be quite a good thing. We can rebuild their country. We can purge the left.
保守派一直鄙视法国民主，就像德国保守派鄙视魏玛共和国一样。你知道，法国保守派经常钦佩希特勒和墨索里尼，并谈论可以从法西斯主义中吸取的教训。所以当他们被打败时，他们说，好吧，你知道吗，实际上，这可能是一件好事。我们可以重建他们的国家。我们可以清洗左派。
You know, this is actually a necessary lesson for us and we can, you know, learn from it. Which suggests that they haven't properly understood what the Nazis are about, right? Yeah. Or that they have and they're just terrible people. I think the former, because I think that the French right are patriotic. I mean, Petin was the great hero of France. He thinks that what he's doing is for the best for France, but it's mad to think. think that the Nazis will cut France any slack at all, because for them, their triumph is
你知道，这对我们来说实际上是一个必要的教训，我们可以从中学习。这表明他们没有正确理解纳粹到底是什么，对吧？是的。或者他们理解了，他们只是糟糕的人。我认为是前者，因为我认为法国右翼是爱国的。我是说，贝当是法国的伟大英雄。他认为他所做的是为了法国好，但认为纳粹会给法国任何喘息机会是疯狂的，因为对他们来说，他们的胜利是
so transcendent. I mean, they're interpreting it in racial and cultural terms, aren't they? Of course they are. Of course they are. Transcendent is the word. I mean, Hitler, when he heard Peyton has broadcast, he was described by people there as literally slapping his thighs with joy. That's not an image anyone wants to see. His tight leather trousers. So Hitler assumes the war is over. The next day he flies to Munich to meet Mussoling. The Italians, the Italians, I mean, I know we've got some Italian listeners actually. I mean, I'm sorry to say this, but the Italians absolutely disgrace themselves in both world wars for different reasons.
如此超然。我是说，他们是在从种族和文化的角度来解读它，不是吗？当然是。当然是。超然就是这个词。我是说，希特勒在听到贝当的广播时，被在场的人描述为简直是在高兴地拍打大腿。那不是任何人想看到的画面。他那紧身的皮裤。所以希特勒认为战争结束了。第二天他飞往慕尼黑会见墨索里尼。意大利人，意大利人，我是说，我知道我们实际上有一些意大利听众。我是说，我很抱歉这么说，但意大利人在两次世界大战中都因为不同的原因彻底丢尽了脸。
So in this World War, they've done their traditional thing of sitting on the sidelines at first. Mussolini's, you know, he's not really interested in the West. His ambitions are in the Adriatic, kind of Yugoslavia and Greece. But Mussolini is a total snake. And he declared war on Britain at France on the 10th of June. I mean, it's literally like, you know, taking part in a football match in the 85th minute or something. Do you know who would agree with you that Mussolini disgraced himself with his Declaration of War?
所以在这场世界大战中，他们做了他们传统的做法，起初坐在场边。墨索里尼，你知道，他并不真正关心西方。他的野心在亚得里亚海，类似于南斯拉夫和希腊。但墨索里尼是一条彻头彻尾的毒蛇。他在6月10日对英国和法国宣战。我是说，这简直就像，你知道，在第85分钟参加一场足球比赛之类的。你知道谁会同意你的观点，即墨索里尼因其宣战而丢尽了脸吗？
Oh, don't compare me with some hideous Nazi. Hitler. Right back, I knew that was coming. To quote my brother in War in the West, he thought that Mussolini declaring war was pathetic. As far as the furor was concerned, one didn't make a declaration of war. One just got on and fought it. So Mussolini had really let himself down there. So Mussolini didn't even, I mean, he declared war just before the Germans capture Paris.
哦，别把我跟什么可怕的纳粹相提并论。希特勒。对了，我就知道会这样。引用我兄弟在《西方战争》中的话，他认为墨索里尼宣战是可悲的。就元首而言，一个人不会宣战。一个人只是继续战斗。所以墨索里尼在那里确实让自己失望了。所以墨索里尼甚至没有——我是说，他在德国人占领巴黎之前就宣战了。
And he said to his cronies, he said basically what I'm hoping is that 2,000 Italians will be killed. And that will be enough for me to claim Corsica and Nice for Italy. I mean, he also said Mussolini, what kind of an ally is Mussolini? He said, I hope Britain doesn't surrender too quickly because I'd like to take some of the credit for it somewhere. and Hitler will get all the credit. And he also said, I hope that Hitler does end up attacking Britain and does invade Britain
他对他的亲信说，他基本上说我希望的是有2000名意大利人被杀。那对我来说就足够去要求意大利获得科西嘉岛和尼斯了。我是说，他还说，墨索里尼，墨索里尼算什么盟友？他说，我希望英国不要投降得太快，因为我想在其中分得一些功劳。而希特勒会得到所有的功劳。他还说，我希望希特勒最终攻击英国并入侵英国，
because I think he'll lose a million men and that will be good for him and it'll mean the Germans aren't too cocky after the war when they've won. Anyway, they meet in Munich. And now this is interesting, think about Britain. Because we know from the Italian Foreign Minister,
因为我认为他会损失一百万人，这对他是件好事，这意味着德国人在战争获胜后不会太自大。总之，他们在慕尼黑会面。现在这很有趣，想想英国。因为我们从意大利外交部长那里知道，
Count Gianno, what Hitler thought was going to happen. He said, Hitler really wants to end this quickly now. He's like a gambler. He's better all his job. chips, he's had a big winning, and he wants to scoop everything up. Hitler says to Chiano, I really don't want Britain to fall apart completely and lose its empire. Because Britain losing its empire would be great news for our other rivals, the United States, Japan, and the Soviet Union. They would be the big winners, not Germany. So basically, I want Britain to
齐亚诺伯爵，希特勒认为会发生什么。他说，希特勒现在真的想尽快结束这一切。他就像个赌徒。他押上了他所有的筹码，他赢了一大笔，他想把一切都捞走。希特勒对齐亚诺说，我真的不想让英国彻底崩溃并失去它的帝国。因为英国失去帝国对我们的其他竞争对手——美国、日本和苏联——来说将是天大的好消息。他们将是赢家，而不是德国。所以基本上，我希望英国
keep its empire. Now, we will see how that plays out next time. But for the time being, Hitler's priority is to give the war in France the ending that he feels he deserves. Remember, I mean, you mentioned at the beginning how important the experience of defeat in 1918 had been to Hitler. You know, the scene when he's in the sanatorium in Passavalk, wherever it is, and he's sobbing like a baby when he hears the news. Now he's going to have his revenge. And as soon as the German tanks had reached the Channel Coast, you know, the beginning of the invasion, he'd said to his AIDS. When we win, I want to have the armistice negotiations in the Compienne Forest in the same spot where we surrendered in 1918. And not only that, we surrendered in a railway carriage in
保留它的帝国。现在，我们将看看下次会如何发展。但目前，希特勒的首要任务是给法国的战争一个他认为应得的结局。记住，我是说，你在一开始提到了1918年的失败经历对希特勒有多重要。你知道，当他在帕瑟瓦尔克的疗养院时，无论在哪里，当他听到消息时像个婴儿一样啜泣的场景。现在他要复仇了。当德国坦克到达海峡海岸时，你知道，入侵的开始，他曾对他的助手说。当我们获胜时，我希望在贡比涅森林进行停战谈判，就在我们1918年投降的同一个地方。不仅如此，我们在
18 to Marshall Foch. I want to get the same railway carriage and then we'll force the French to be on the receiving end this time. And they did. They tracked it down to a museum. A German demolition crew broke down the walls of this museum with a kind of J.C.B. type thing. They dragged out the railway carriage and they took it all the way to this forest and dumped it in the forest. And the ceremony is set for the 21st of June. Three o'clock that afternoon, Hitler turns up with all the gang, Gurring, Ribbentrop, Hess, all these characters. He had a look at the French War Memorial, which was in the forest. Then he went into the carriage. The French had already arrived. They're sitting there in absolutely glum silence. Hitler sat exactly where the
18年在一节火车车厢里向福煦元帅投降。我想要得到同一节火车车厢，然后这次我们要强迫法国人成为接受方。他们确实这么做了。他们把它追踪到一个博物馆。一个德国拆除小组用一种J.C.B.类型的机器拆毁了博物馆的墙壁。他们拖出了那节火车车厢，一路把它带到这片森林，并把它扔在森林里。仪式定于6月21日举行。那天下午三点，希特勒带着所有的帮派出现了，戈林、里宾特洛甫、赫斯，所有这些角色。他看了一眼森林里的法国战争纪念碑。然后他进了车厢。法国人已经到了。他们坐在那里，陷入了绝对阴郁的沉默。希特勒坐在了完全是那个
Supreme Allied commander, Marshal Foch, has sat in 1918. And the American reporter William Shirea, who saw Hitler that day, said, I've seen that face many times at the great moments of his life, but today it is a fire with scorn, anger, hate, revenge, triumph. General Keitel read the preamble to the armistice, which said that, basically, the German, people have been suffering and humiliated for 20 years, but that's over now and justice has been restored. And then Hitler just walked out, a gesture of contempt for the French. I will leave the rest to my underlings. That's again what Foch had done to the Germans, isn't it? So again and again, it's treating the French how they had treated the Germans.
1918年，盟军最高统帅福煦元帅曾坐在这里。那天见到希特勒的美国记者威廉·夏伊勒说：“我曾多次在他生命中的重大时刻见过那张脸，但今天，那张脸上燃烧着蔑视、愤怒、仇恨、复仇和胜利的火焰。”凯特尔将军宣读了停战协定的序言，大意是德国人民遭受了20年的苦难和羞辱，但现在这一切都结束了，正义得到了恢复。随后，希特勒径直走了出去，这是对法国人的一种蔑视姿态。我把剩下的事留给我的下属去处理。这又是福煦当年对德国人做过的事，不是吗？所以，这又是一次以其人之道还治其人之身，用法国人对待德国人的方式对待法国人。
Exactly. And I mean, Hitler and his cronies don't disguise how personal this is. Because that evening, Hitler ran Goebbels in Berlin to talk it through, and Goebbels wrote in his diary afterwards, the disgrace is now extinguished. It's a feeling of being born again, this sort of sense of vindication and revenge after the First World War. So what terms are the French able to get? Well, the French don't have a leg to stand on. They just have to take what they're given effectively, much as they sort of beg for better. So they lose Alsatina reign, Germany takes them back, northern and western France becomes a German military occupied zone, and then the southern two-fifths of France will be governed by Marshal Peta from the spa town of Vichy. We know that the Nazis love spa towns.
没错。我的意思是，希特勒和他的亲信们毫不掩饰这件事有多么私人化。因为那天晚上，希特勒在柏林给戈培尔打电话讨论这件事，戈培尔事后在日记中写道：“耻辱现在被洗刷了。”这是一种重获新生的感觉，一种在第一次世界大战后寻求平反和复仇的感觉。那么法国人能得到什么条款呢？好吧，法国人根本没有谈判的筹码。他们实际上只能接受被强加的条件，尽管他们试图乞求更好的待遇。所以他们失去了阿尔萨斯-洛林，德国收回了这些领土，法国北部和西部成为德国军事占领区，而法国南部五分之二的地区将由贝当元帅在维希温泉小镇进行统治。我们知道纳粹喜欢温泉小镇。
And Marshall Pater ends up presiding over this very reactionary, repressive, anti-Semitic regime, which is a subject for another day, I guess. And when Hitler heard the news that the French had signed, I mean, again, it's the sign of the sort of almost like the malevolent teenage boy in Hitler, I think. Yeah. He said, turn out all the lights in the headquarters, everything in darkness, and open all the windows. I want nothing to disturb the sound of the trumpeter marking the moment of the French surrender. You know, he just wants to absolutely wallow in that moment of vindication. So the same day, which is the 22nd of June, the Vermacht organized this huge victory parade in Paris. You can see it on YouTube, actually, on German newsreels, troops marching down the Chonseilier, cavalry riding past the Arc de Triumph.
贝当元帅最终主持了这个非常反动、压迫、反犹太的政权，我想这又是另一个话题了。当希特勒听到法国人签署协议的消息时，我的意思是，这再次显示了希特勒身上那种近乎恶毒的少年心态。他说：“关掉总部所有的灯，让一切陷入黑暗，打开所有的窗户。我不希望任何声音打扰到那名吹号手，他要吹响法国投降的时刻。”你知道，他只是想彻底沉浸在那一刻的平反感中。所以同一天，也就是6月22日，德国国防军在巴黎组织了一场盛大的胜利游行。你实际上可以在YouTube上看到德国的新闻短片，部队沿着香榭丽舍大街行进，骑兵骑马经过凯旋门。
I mean, imagine being a German, you know, a nationalistic German, back in Cologne or Hamburg or Stuttgart or whatever, watching this in the cinema with your compatriots. That sense that Hitler has a vindication and revenge, that's what lots, millions of ordinary Germans thought at that moment. But also presumably they're thinking, Hitler was right. Everything he promised us has come to pass. Of course they are. So the bells ring across the Reich for a week. The flags are hoisted for 10 days. You know, there had been massive celebrations with the reports of things like the fall of Paris.
想象一下，作为一个德国人，一个民族主义的德国人，在科隆、汉堡或斯图加特等地，和你的同胞在电影院里观看这一幕。那种希特勒带来的平反和复仇感，正是当时数百万普通德国人的想法。但他们可能也在想，希特勒是对的。他向我们承诺的一切都实现了。当然他们会这么想。所以整个帝国响起了长达一周的钟声。旗帜悬挂了10天。你知道，随着巴黎陷落的消息传来，到处都在举行大规模的庆祝活动。
And we've talked many times in this series about how actually. anxious Germans were about another world war, but all their anxieties, it seems, have been put at rest. I mean, Hitler, you're exactly right, Tom. What they think is even people who doubted Hitler now say, do you know what, he was right? He accomplished everything that he said he would. SS reports, we know from SS Security Service reports that even among people who were skeptical of the regime, who were even perhaps on the more dissident side of things,
我们在本系列中多次谈到德国人对另一场世界大战实际上有多么焦虑，但他们所有的焦虑似乎都烟消云散了。我的意思是，希特勒，你说得完全对，汤姆。他们认为，即使是那些怀疑希特勒的人现在也说，你知道吗，他是对的？他完成了他所说的一切。我们从党卫军安全局的报告中得知，即使在那些对政权持怀疑态度，甚至可能站在异见立场的人中，
now are just full of admiration for what has been achieved in France. There's a brilliant example. Richard Evans in his great books on the Third Reich. He has a number of diarists that he cites again and again. One of them is this woman called Louisa Solmits. I think we mentioned her in previous series. She was a school teacher. She was conservative.
现在也对在法国取得的成就充满了钦佩。有一个绝佳的例子。理查德·埃文斯在他关于第三帝国的伟大著作中，引用了多位日记作者的话。其中一位是名叫路易莎·索尔米茨的女性。我想我们在之前的系列中提到过她。她是一名教师。她是保守派。
But her husband was Jewish. So she was quite conflicted, as you would expect, about the regime. But now, she writes in her diary, she says, I feel exhilarated by happiness and enthusiasm. It's an unbelievably great national change of fortune, the fulfillment of our long-held dreams. And Dominic, if she is feeling like that, how does Hitler feel? Oh, I mean, like that, but only more so. You know, the way that, again, I compared him rather flippantly to a sort of teenage boy. But, you know, what does Hitler do?
但她的丈夫是犹太人。所以正如你所料，她对这个政权感到非常矛盾。但现在，她在日记中写道，她说：“我感到幸福和热情洋溢。这是国家命运不可思议的巨大改变，是我们长期梦想的实现。”多米尼克，如果她有这种感觉，希特勒会是什么感觉？哦，我的意思是，也是那种感觉，但程度更深。你知道，我刚才轻率地把他比作一个少年。但是，你知道希特勒做了什么？
he spends the next couple of days of visiting battlefields in Flanders with old comrades with his old company sergeant from the First World War and a fellow dispatch runner and then that thing of the boyhood dream
他接下来的几天都在与老战友、他在一战时的老连队军士长以及一位通讯兵一起参观佛兰德斯的战场，然后就是那个儿时的梦想，
visiting Paris so as Speer described in that reading that you did at the beginning he flew in with his favourite architects and his photographer Heinrich Hoffman they went to the opera first
参观巴黎。正如施佩尔在你开头读的那段话中所描述的那样，他带着他最喜欢的建筑师和摄影师海因里希·霍夫曼飞了过去，他们先去了歌剧院，
and they were showed around by a caretaker and they offered the caretaker a tip but the caretaker didn't, wouldn't accept it You know, obviously he doesn't want to take German gold. They went to all those places that Speer mentioned the Arc to Triumph, the Avali, the Pontillon, and so on, Tomb of Napoleon.
他们由一名看门人带领参观，他们给了看门人小费，但看门人拒绝接受。你知道，显然他不想拿德国人的钱。他们去了施佩尔提到的所有地方，凯旋门、埃菲尔铁塔、荣军院等等，拿破仑的墓。
The interesting thing is Hitler said afterwards to Goebbels, you know, Paris wasn't as good as I thought it would be. I thought it would be more impressive. And then he said to Speer that evening, he said, I'd always thought we'd have to destroy Paris. But now I've realized that basically when we're done in Berlin, Berlin will be much better and Paris will only be a shadow. So we don't need to destroy it. So weirdly, if Paris had been more impressive, Hitler would have destroyed it. And then at last he makes his triumphant return to Germany, choreographed by Goebbels on the afternoon of the 6th of July. And this really, I mean, we were talking at the beginning, weren't we, about what was the happiest moment, was the high point of Hitler's life?
有趣的是，希特勒后来对戈培尔说：“你知道，巴黎并没有我想象中那么好。我以为它会更令人印象深刻。”然后那天晚上他对施佩尔说：“我一直以为我们必须摧毁巴黎。但现在我意识到，基本上当我们完成柏林的改造后，柏林会好得多，巴黎只会是一个影子。所以我们不需要摧毁它。”所以奇怪的是，如果巴黎更令人印象深刻，希特勒反而会摧毁它。最后，他在7月6日下午回到了德国，这是由戈培尔精心策划的凯旋归来。这真的，我的意思是，我们刚才在开头谈论过，什么是希特勒一生中最快乐的时刻，最高点？
This has got to be up there. Massive crowds, hundreds of thousands of people, they have strewn the streets with flowers. He goes all the way from the station to the Reich Chancellor in the centre, and there General Keitel introduces him as the greatest warlord of all time, and people are screaming and sobbing, and Hitler comes out again and again to salute the crowds, and he is at the summit. He is at the zenith now, because there's only one enemy left, Britain. He is preparing his final peace offer to Britain. If Churchill refuses that, then he will bring the British to their knees.
这绝对算得上。人群拥挤，成千上万的人，他们向街道上撒满了鲜花。他从车站一直走到市中心的帝国总理府，凯特尔将军在那里介绍他是“有史以来最伟大的统帅”，人们尖叫着、哭泣着，希特勒一次又一次地出来向人群致敬，他现在处于巅峰。他处于顶峰，因为只剩下一个敌人了，英国。他正在准备给英国的最后和平提议。如果丘吉尔拒绝，那么他将让英国人屈膝投降。
And as the operations chief of his army general Yodel writes in his diary, the final German victory over England is now just a question of time. Or is it? We will find out in our final episode of this series. It's the great duel between Hitler and and Winston Churchill between the Luftwaffe and the RAF as we look at the Battle of Britain, the Blitz, and the build-up to Operation Barbarossa. And members of the Restis History Club can, of course, hear that episode right now.
正如他的陆军作战部长约德尔在日记中所写的那样，德国对英国的最终胜利现在只是时间问题。真的是这样吗？我们将在本系列的最后一集中找到答案。这是希特勒与温斯顿·丘吉尔之间、德国空军与英国皇家空军之间的伟大决斗，我们将审视不列颠战役、闪电战以及巴巴罗萨行动的准备工作。当然，历史俱乐部（Restis History Club）的成员现在就可以收听那一集。
And if you would like to join them and hear about Britain's finest hour, then please do sign up at the rest is history.com. Auvoir. Avaluze. Throughout time, celebration has mentioned. giving. So the Romans at Saturnalia handed out all kinds of gifts. The three magi handed out gold, frankincense and myrrh, and the Victorians absolutely loved wrapping things up in paper and then tying it up in string. So on those are lovely gestures, but I wonder if they're a little bit too extravagant
如果你想加入他们并了解英国最辉煌的时刻，请在therestishistory.com注册。再见。纵观历史，庆祝活动意味着给予。罗马人在农神节上分发各种礼物。三位智者赠送了黄金、乳香和没药，维多利亚时代的人非常喜欢用纸包装东西，然后用绳子系起来。这些都是可爱的姿态，但我怀疑它们是否有点太奢侈了，
for the typical Christmas morning. So this year, here's my suggestion to our listeners and our viewers, why not give something a little bit more enlightened? Why not give the gift of the rest of It's history club membership. It's the discerning choice for anybody who prefers a Hannibal to a hamper. It's ad-free listening. You get a weekly bonus episode. You get early access to live shows. And you get exclusive deep dive series.
对于典型的圣诞节早晨来说。所以今年，这是我给听众和观众的建议，为什么不送一些更有启发性的礼物呢？为什么不送一份历史俱乐部（Restis History Club）的会员资格作为礼物？对于任何喜欢汉尼拔胜过喜欢礼品篮的人来说，这是一个有眼光的选择。它是无广告收听。你每周会得到一集额外节目。你可以提前观看现场演出。你还可以获得独家的深度系列节目。
Also, on top of that, this year's special gift edition of Restis History Club membership, comes with a sensational exclusive t-shirt. It will make you the envy of all your neighbours and all the... the cool people in your neighbourhood, if such people exist, will admire you and want to spend more time with you. So just head to therestishistory.com and click on gifts. That is therestishistory.com and please click on gifts. Throughout time, celebration has meant giving. So the Romans at Saturnalia handed out all kinds of gifts. The three magi handed out gold, frankincense and myrrh. And the Victorians absolutely loved
此外，今年历史俱乐部会员资格的特别礼品版还附带一件轰动性的独家T恤。它会让你成为所有邻居羡慕的对象，你社区里所有酷的人，如果这样的人存在的话，都会钦佩你并想花更多时间和你在一起。所以只需前往therestishistory.com并点击“礼物”。那是therestishistory.com，请点击“礼物”。纵观历史，庆祝活动意味着给予。罗马人在农神节上分发各种礼物。三位智者赠送了黄金、乳香和没药。维多利亚时代的人非常喜欢
wrapping things up in paper and then tying it up in string. It's on those are lovely gestures, but I wonder if they're a little bit too extravagant for the typical Christmas morning. So this year, here's my suggestion to our listeners and our viewers. Why not give something a little bit more enlightened? Why not give the gifts? of the Restis History Club membership. It's the discerning choice for anybody who prefers a Hannibal to a hamper. It's ad-free listening.
用纸包装东西，然后用绳子系起来。这些都是可爱的姿态，但我怀疑它们是否对于典型的圣诞节早晨来说太奢侈了。所以今年，这是我给听众和观众的建议。为什么不送一些更有启发性的礼物呢？为什么不送一份历史俱乐部会员资格作为礼物？对于任何喜欢汉尼拔胜过喜欢礼品篮的人来说，这是一个有眼光的选择。它是无广告收听。
You get a weekly bonus episode. You get early access to live shows and you get exclusive deep dive series. Also, on top of that, this year's special gift edition of Restis History Club membership comes with a sensational exclusive t-shirt. It will make you the envy
你每周会得到一集额外节目。你可以提前观看现场演出，还可以获得独家的深度系列节目。此外，今年历史俱乐部会员资格的特别礼品版还附带一件轰动性的独家T恤。它会让你成为羡慕的对象，
of all your neighbours and all the cool people in your neighbourhood, if such people exist, will admire you and want to spend more time with you. So just head to the rest ishistory.com and click on gifts. That is therestishistory.com and please click on gifts. Hello there, it's James Holland and Al Murray, hosts of WW2Pod. We have ways of making you talk. Yes, so Al and I have been on The Rest of History a few times now, haven't we, Al? We've been talking all things World War II with Tom and Dominic.
你社区里所有酷的人，如果这样的人存在的话，都会钦佩你并想花更多时间和你在一起。所以只需前往therestishistory.com并点击“礼物”。那是therestishistory.com，请点击“礼物”。你好，我是詹姆斯·霍兰德和阿尔·默里，二战播客《我们有办法让你开口》（WW2Pod, We Have Ways of Making You Talk）的主持人。是的，阿尔和我已经上过几次《历史的其余部分》（The Rest of History）了，不是吗，阿尔？我们一直在和汤姆和多米尼克谈论二战的所有事情。
And if you've been enjoying their recent series on the invasion of Norway, the fall of France and the Battle of Britain, then we have good news for you. That's right, Jim. We have our own show all about the fascinating history of the Second World War. We've been going for longer than the Second World War itself, haven't we, James? And longer than the rest is history. Twice a week. WW2Pod, we have ways to make you talk,
如果你一直喜欢他们最近关于入侵挪威、法国陷落和不列颠战役的系列节目，那么我们有好消息告诉你。没错，吉姆。我们有自己的节目，专门讲述二战迷人的历史。我们做节目的时间比二战本身还要长，不是吗，詹姆斯？而且比《历史的其余部分》还要长。每周两次。《我们有办法让你开口》，
discusses the fascinating people, the incredible innovations, and the terrible tragedy. of this, I think, the most important period of history of all time. Absolutely. The Battle of Hastings. I've got nothing on this. It's 1940, where it's all at. This past year alone now, we've done series, haven't we, on Dunkirk, the Battle of Britain, Hitler's last days in Berlin, the dropping of the atomic bombs. And we've also explored the women of SOE, Auschwitz, and the nerve-wracking siege of Malta. And in a midst of all this, we take our listeners' family stories and give them an airing so that people can tell the story of what happened to their Uncle Albert, where maybe they were involved. for the Siege of Malta.
讨论迷人的人物、令人难以置信的创新以及可怕的悲剧。我认为这是历史上最重要的时期。绝对是。黑斯廷斯战役。我对此一无所知。1940年才是重点。仅在过去的一年里，我们就制作了关于敦刻尔克、不列颠战役、希特勒在柏林的最后日子、原子弹投下的系列节目。我们还探索了特别行动执行处（SOE）的女性、奥斯威辛集中营以及令人神经紧张的马耳他围城战。在所有这些之中，我们采纳了听众的家庭故事并将其播出，这样人们就可以讲述他们阿尔伯特叔叔身上发生的事情，也许他们参与了马耳他围城战。
And we're doing loads of naval chat at the moment on the main show, such as the fight against the U-boat Wolfpacks in the Atlantic War. So now is a really fantastic time to subscribe and get yourself a bit more nautical. So, search, We Have Ways, wherever you get your podcasts, and we look forward to you joining us. Prepare to Board, we have Ways to Make You Talk with me, Al Murray, and James Holland. Thank you. Hello there, I'm William Drimple.
我们目前在主节目中进行了大量的海军聊天，例如在大西洋战争中对抗U型潜艇狼群。所以现在是订阅并让自己多了解一点航海知识的绝佳时机。所以，在任何你获取播客的地方搜索“We Have Ways”，我们期待你的加入。准备登船，《我们有办法让你开口》，主持人是我阿尔·默里和詹姆斯·霍兰德。谢谢。你好，我是威廉·达林普尔。
And one of the hosts of Empire, the Global History Podcast from Goalhanger. You may remember my appearances on The Rest is History when we talked about Afghanistan and the East India Company. As The Ashes returned down under, Anita Anna and I have launched a brand new Empire series on the history, politics, and extraordinary cultural power of cricket. In the first episode, we dig into the origin of the ashes, England versus Australia, a rivalry born in the age of empires, and still shaping identity on both. sides of the world. Then we travelled to India where cricket began with an impromptu beach match
我是Goalhanger出品的全球历史播客《帝国》（Empire）的主持人之一。你可能还记得我在《历史的其余部分》中的表现，当时我们谈论了阿富汗和东印度公司。随着灰烬杯（The Ashes）板球赛回归，安妮塔·阿南德和我推出了一个全新的《帝国》系列，探讨板球的历史、政治和非凡的文化力量。在第一集中，我们深入挖掘了灰烬杯的起源，英格兰对阵澳大利亚，这是一场诞生于帝国时代的竞争，至今仍在塑造着世界两端的身份认同。
and evolved into a sport that mirrored and sometimes magnified the country's communal divides. We also talk about the great Tiger Borti who revolutionised Indian cricket in the 1960s. And for members of the Empire Club, we go still further from the great West Indian players who stood up to racism to the South African cricketers who challenged apartheid at real personal risk. If you want the full sweep of how cricket changed empires and how empire, change cricket, just search for Empire wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
然后我们前往印度，板球在那里始于一场即兴的海滩比赛，并演变成一项反映并有时放大了该国社区分歧的运动。我们还谈到了在20世纪60年代彻底改变印度板球运动的伟大球员老虎·帕托迪。对于《帝国》俱乐部的成员，我们走得更远，从反抗种族主义的伟大西印度群岛球员，到冒着个人风险挑战种族隔离制度的南非板球运动员。如果你想全面了解板球如何改变了帝国，以及帝国如何改变了板球，只需在任何你获取播客的地方搜索“Empire”。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。